vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast qui est en
croissance constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel bien qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec écoute le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
production du f
[Musique]
bienvenue ou sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
date située à saint quentin avec moi
d'une plante à un dernier quart de
l'année ouvriers 2020 j'espère que ça
n'a pas été trop peu on est passé au
travers le russe ilya encore en vie
on fait une petite rétrospective de
l'année
nos coups de coeur moment coup de coeur
de l'année au podcast on va mettre des
extraits on vous en a parlé c'est juste
le fph mais c'est bon pareil même si la
naïveté son épopée y on est capable fait
que pâques est fixé ce qui en fait
droite puis si vous voulez nous donner
un cadeau pour le nouvel an c'est là que
ça se passe
on fait des shows après tout les shows d
après show qui s'appelle encore moins
field où est-ce qu'on jase ou est ce
qu'on parle du podcast whisky ou escofet
contenu dans le fond exclusif au monde
et tu en fais qu'aller voir là dessus
puis sinon on le dit en fin de ce
podcast mais on leur dit maintenant
merci à vous toutes et tous d'être là
parce que ça aux autres
y'a pas de sans fil pas de gaza sans fil
podcast honnêtement je ne sais pas
qu'est ce que je ferai dans ma vie mais
là au moins c'est sûr c'est la feqgae
avec merci sachez que only tous vos
commentaires on sait on est content
soyez là merci la gagne puis à bon écho
depuis à bonbonne fine 2020 et puis bon
2000 watts et rouillée
[Musique]
il est né le divin enfant jouez hautbois
résonnez musettes futur jouer à mohéli
elle peut aller mais c'est la grande
question c'est notre spécial nouvel an
yes papa de 15 jours de la dernière de
l'année pour l'année comme un beau petit
cadeau rétrospective et prospective ou
est-ce qu'on s'assoit puis on réfléchit
sur l'année qu'on vient de passer comme
un émetteur mettons que tu aurais donné
at on donné personnellement c'est au
delà de 2020 en tant qu anne est
merdique pour la planète au complet mais
tant que le temps que je prends soin
comfec enlève deux à la note que tu
donnerais ton année normale mais dont je
dirais qu 1,5 et 1,7 dans une situation
normale c'est dur à dire le cdj adq et
aimer ton monte à nice pour le même si
même si c'était une dure année pour tous
soins on est content que ça se tient
pendant que s'achève on espère qu'il
aimait le 21 sera meilleur plus plus
paisible plus les plus paisibles pitié
je dois ça finit bien quand même
l'arrivée de la venue d'un vaccin
c'est comme les gens un peu lever de
soleil 2021 et on dirait que soleil une
leur d'espoir ligne une page un chapitre
qui se terminent les vaches qui se
tourne
il ya comme une image qui me vient une
marche poétique c'est comme une lumière
au bout du tunnel
je suis la première personne qui imagine
un long tunnel noir mais au bout il ya
une lueur une lumière rouge pour nos
auditeurs enfin premièrement merci
d'avoir été avec nous à toute l'année on
veut sûrement vous remercier encore à la
fin mai
running back depuis mon oeil pendant
longtemps c'était tout le temps de
prendre un concept qui était vraiment
évident puis clichés une expression ou
est ce qui nous tue pas nous rend plus
forts par exemple depuis toujours essayé
de l'expliquer comme si quelqu'un qui
avait jamais entendu cette expression
imagine mais ton teint vers le quai
dedans il ya de l'eau ou le liquide de
ton choix
il est vraiment juste à la moitié c'est
toi qui décide si tu le vois à moitié
vide ou à moitié plein non non moi moi
mon année même moi je veux me donner 1 3
le sida neymar auteur nous mettons en
temps normal ce sera 1 5 parce que je
quelqu'un quand même optimiste c'est
exact mais là avec la coved en plus me
donner un bon trop le nez pour prat le
bon vieux pitou des échelles bon vieux
ph est passé à brûler
oh mais on dit que l'année mène à la
durée 10 c'est fou c'est fou quand je
pense à tout ce qui s'est passé dans
l'année mettons autant au niveau
personnel que dans le monde
mendy ce qui s'est passé en janvier
février passé l'australie qui brûlait
manque-t-il au dessus il y avait des
photos de kangourou en feu huawei puis
de porter déjà et 2020 puis non men ccgt
team étant moi même et on se fait un
mini voyage en marche pour une coupe de
jose états-unis eu l'impression que
c'était une autre réalité c'est clair on
vraiment pire puis on est plein de
changements aussi personnellement c'est
clair c'est clair on espère qu'on va
ressortir grandis tu cite une dizaine
dont on vient leur garde et les podcasts
qu'on m'a faite durant l'année type je
te demandais si quoi que le premier
podcast de 2010 jérémy demay dans ma
tête le podcast qu'on a fait et jérémy
demain mais on dirait que ça fait
saintes s'est tellement passé des
affaires humaines s'est tellement passé
des choses dans ma vie personnelle mans
puis d'en haut sur le podcast puis dans
le monde mène contre et on dirait que
c'est même pas le même univers mais si
mais si on fait des blagues et que la
lumière au bout de finale tendue mais
j'ai vraiment l'impression de couches
relativement optimiste pour la suite le
tir on dirait qu'elle le sait mais il
faut pouvoir
on y avoir 500 vient c'est comme on dit
que wafa qui dit quand on dit que j'ai
pour la prochaine année peut-être les
prochains quatre heures l'autoroute
était peut-être un peu plus sous doute
un petit peu moins tout le temps c'est
noir ou en colère tant pis ça va faire
du bien je vais moi j'ai l'impression
qu'avec la la fin de la coved qui arrive
le ti jos indéniablement les vaccins qui
fonctionne à 95% sont en train d'être
administrés alors où on se parle de ces
faits qu'en ce moment et 10 des
professionnels de santé qui sont déjà
vaccinés partout dans le monde qui sont
voit que ça arrive le titre puis avec
ceux avec la copine qui s'envolent qui
les choses qui réouvre puis les
passe-temps qui vont redevenir chose la
vie courante les à dire les sortie d'un
resto d'un bord acte d'amitié forts du
monde
j'ai l'impression aussi que ça va comme
adoucir le dialogue public des gens que
la seule chose qu'ils ont à faire en ce
moment c'est d'être français par un
scandale
le pied sauté sur le bernois guen de ce
scandale puis sautez sur telle cause de
telles causes je pense ça va jusqu'à
tout le monde va pouvoir respirer un
petit pour vaquer à leurs occupations
pour réaliser qu'au final tout cela
n'est que n'est qu'un des aspects de la
société puis de la vie d'un qu'elles ont
existé et il a mérité de revendications
qui ont lieu cette année ont été
amplifiées par semaine sont totalement
légitime aussi est il nécessaire
certaines étaient indignés parce que
quelqu'un s'est fait abattre par un
policier versus les agissements d'intel
où en était la télé réalité26 pontis par
même afin de jauger de la tille des
niveaux des grèves tpiy long terme
s'indignent à fond la caisse était
quasiment autant de l'autre des
balancements métier tel est le podcast
prix vraiment un virage plus sociale
maintenant à 2020 pitié on dirait que
j'espère qu'en 2020 des tirs ont été
refoulés de la société il m'a dit et on
n'avait pas le choix
mais on a toujours le choix métier on
voulait aborder ces questions là parce
qu'on juge et qui est importante qui est
incontournable dit j'espère qu'on n'aura
pas besoin finalement leur faire serait
trop six engagés socialement en 2021
mais quand vous pour faire d'autres
types de podcasts avec d'autres types de
2 sur d'autres des sujets se doter de ce
type de personne mais parce que le monde
avait disparu stephen colbert qui
disaient ils parlent tous les jours
puis il disait comme moi aussi j'aurais
thème écrire des commentaires moi aussi
je suis tanné
de parler dans notre chambre moi aussi
j'ai juste hâte de pu avoir en en parler
j'ai juste hâte de passer à autre chose
puis de continuer à faire des jokes sur
telle ou telle personne célébrité que
brad pitt a fait téléphone j'ai autres
c'est ça je puis gelé sentir city puis
on le vit peut-être un peu afin de
l'année le jeu peu plus tôt a mentionné
parlé un petit peu le dire on était un
peu essoufflée par par la suite d'enjeux
sociaux qui arrivait puis que nous on
est tanné qu'on voulait les traités sur
le podcast donc on sonne on s'informe et
puis ont baigné là dedans et on allait
chercher l'information mais à fond avec
comme un essoufflement puis peut-être ce
serait la transition pour tomber entre
et respectifs de podcasts de l'année
mais on le sent tic en mettant en fait
le podcast avec jean thomas jobin
ou est-ce que là on est venu ici puis il
n'y avait pas d'enjeu social n'y avait
pas de cause qu'on voulait parler avait
pas de sujet précis c'était de ça et on
va jaser puis comme de fuite je pense
que même le monde un commentaire du
podcast ils l'ont dit en fait à et le ce
paquet cela fait du bien pauvre s écoule
l'on vous écoute ses autres que vous
soyez they call est un petit peu plus
sur l'actualité mais celui là il a fait
respirer un peu puis je l' ai senti
aussi pendant qu'on le faisait le tir
voici on parle même pendant 45 minutes
de se raser les bases respectives les
deux on s'est dit qu'on allait sortir
noël ait mis le paquet sur thomas c'est
ce ne sera pas long terme et si je pense
est un des highlights de l'année on a ri
ce téléphone serait drôle puis toute la
sigma sur la pilosité pour moi ça
m'aurait placé sans dire qu'on a fait un
classique on peut déjà dire que ce
podcast le traversent le temps justin
mais pour le pas-de-calais dans le monde
de notre podcast pour moi c'est
d'essayer des jeux classiques la
discussion sur la pelouse était le
trépied pas seulement drôle si je bébé
tokyo 6 mo/s quand ils me voient comme
est barbu simard
la france est clairement l'humour
déjanté hop c'est parfait c'est comme si
moi je l'avais connu mannequin qu'on
avait 12 ans c est le même que le genre
de jeune adulte layton lui peu importe
que là je vais avoir le médecin qui va
60 ans ils vont encore porter une
casquette parler de multiplier il est
parfait ces genres de monde si on sent
par la priorité du monde qui est au
décor s'avoue réfléchissent d'une
manière différente les tic ont des idées
puissent comme voir ta pensée assez
honteux que tu t'es passé c'est très
flou réflexion le petit lui six
clairement il ya le trot c'est normal
c'est juste normal qu'il vienne mais
s'ouvre aux jeux mais c'était vraiment
bon et que son colloque la sécu qui
demandent des rased discret mais le dos
plus outre les gosses que vous pose
souvent on va vous remettre des extrêmes
vos motos petit extrait de ce bootleg
nos extraits nicole doit s'occuper de
ces extraits extrait vrai c'est ça que
je pense à raser à pire bonne idée parce
que toutes les écluses de la pie xii
mais je sais pas je pense que c'est un
mythe le fait c'est ça que le moment où
ça repousse sa pique pile sur sa paye ta
main mais je pense que c'est un mythe
que genre qui truste voir venir avec
plus de poids limite
j'ai entendu certains mettent aussi
ouais ouais d'affaires situé par la
mouche parce que moi je fais toujours
bien attention car je me rase pour pas
monter trop haut pour pau rendra loin et
provoque il
mais ça arrive pas mais j'ai quand même
l'impression que quelqu'un va t'en parce
que gm a rappelé des jobs de tous et
chauffage et les obsédés par monde dans
mon premier show choisir le numéro 15 un
petit bébé téléguidé je faisais comme si
je veux pratiquer pour être papa plus
qu'un jeu par les usages envie souvent
de trois et il y avait jean mathon jeudi
qu'ils avaient c'est moi
girardi joulaud botul des barbus jarrah
un an et demi c'est ça mais bon j'ai
quand même l'impression gpo thomas temps
que je me rase lefranc classe qu'il n'y
a pas de poids tant ce serait quand même
fou des barbes de francs ça serait un
bob le chef vaudois
[Musique]
fax et l extrême contre les pauvres rtt
alexis qui fait les extrêmes qui avait t
on les écoute et mettons lui choisi un
extrait i pour ce lundi
this was parle puis le petit avait
choisi un extrait de gentils mots je
peux peut-être la moins aboutie du moins
pigeon j'écoutais des fois les rejette
le cas j'ai eu deux minutes c'est juste
un autre pas de casque qui est faite
récemment fait qui est sortie la semaine
aujourd'hui semaine loin on sort celui
le 29 dans le deux semaines avec sonia
lupien
chi chi chi moite et on vient de le
faire mais qui définitivement dans les
meilleurs de l'année des podcasts les
plus définitivement instructif et
éducatif est utile aussi qu'on a faits
puis justement dans cette espèce
d'ambiance de dust est speed anxiété et
contre la pandémie toutes sortes
d'affaires ça fait vraiment du bien et
qui justement t on parlait de testa
pourtant est engagée c'est important de
parler de toutes les causes mais c'est
important aussi attention à sa santé
mentale
c'est elle qui dit ces deux poutres qui
l'écoutent pas tellement les nouvelles
parce que c'est beaucoup
nouvelle sa mort ça m'a fait remettre un
petit peu en perspective
seul type yamani le jeu me donne plus le
droit maintenant on dirait deux des
plugins pi2 dire de prendre des moments
où est-ce qu'ils s'entendent pas de
parler ou de passer à tous ce parce
qu'elle a mené vous faut prendre soin de
soi aussi nous contre la daf qui s'est
foulé tipi joie vraiment +13 la même
manière depuis six ans les podcasts
parce que le plus influencé mon
quotidien
- parce que leur maintenant quand je
ressens du stress je le reconnais mieux
je reconnais mieux pourquoi y est là
je sais plus quoi faire quand quelqu'un
dit dépenser son énergie réellement
maintenant le titre y faire c'est le
jour qu'a choisi des push up puis je
faisais des sports ou juste des moments
où est ce qu'elle est il ya un build up
puissante à la boule dans le vent
d'aller courir à ce moment l'unsa
relâche tout 16 vraiment du bien ou de
pain pâtes activité physique et tipis
tendance qui est sonia disait de
déconstruire peut-être qu'on pourrait
mettre cet extrait le je pense
d'apprendre à déconstruire sa source de
stress quand il parlait de ce mois c'est
la chose que je fais maintenant
dernièrement j'ai vécu beaucoup de
stress mais dans les derniers des
dernières semaines
puis quand j'ai cette boule dans le
ventre qui me pose je me dis ok les
quatre facteurs de stress voici les
quatre points j'ai établi les quatre
pour moi puis juste de faire ce travail
là ça me permet de comprendre le stress
vient d'où
ça me permet de voir à qui j'ai pas le
contrôle dessus fait que ça sert à rien
qui échoit stressé c'est de l'inconnu
c'est la nouveauté
je lisais les quatre la tête à la
nouveauté de l'imprévisibilité le
sentiment que tout manque de contrôle
piteux l'atteinte à ton égo oui exact
c'est quand tu comprends surtout cadel
de construire de réaliser la boule on
dirait qu'à se dénoue pic à 100 voix
puis piquent risques ça fait un
changement majeur lequel vivent avec ce
puissant coincé dans ce truc c'est moins
une chose qui a marqué mercredi le pc
serment presse canadienne ou telle zone
même mais ça m'a vraiment marqué puis
maintient qu'elle ait dit me la pète une
coche l'an pandémie puis je me suis mis
à penser autour de moi puis en moins -
puis je te le c'est tellement vrai
qu'elle dise exactement deux semaines à
lundi la date de cette fin de semaine
leurs pensées à vauville puis quand ça a
été un logo complète deux semaines à peu
près à plus ou moins 3 jours vous avez
peut-être que c'est quelqu'un que cette
femme le tiki connu
stress mais qui tombe donc comment gérer
tout les trucs que les applique
qu'est elle pète une coche à son fils
parce que ce qui se fait battre au
scrabble je trouve ça malades sexy
vraiment finalement sarivo littéralement
mon meilleur temps ça me rend vraiment
plus empathique quand je vois du monde
justement être impatient ou justement
péter des cochons outil parce que le jeu
le dira réponse normale à un stress mal
canalisée s'est bien vengé en fait c'est
comme ça et puis moi mais ils mettront
je cours d'histoire l'autre jour tee
shirt et les trois semaines dans une
salle de spectacle répétés puis tourné
un vidéo avec un berne le pari qu'une
chanteuse pigeât il ya eu beaucoup de
ces sacrifices accrochage pendant les
trois jours du début des petits trucs
plate qui s'accumulaient des titres
pilotes et la gestion de toutes sortes
de monde en même temps et les
techniciens y avait le band il ya des
personnalités fortes qui avait été dit
ddb manque de communication d
incompréhension de ce pilot deux
premières journées tout a bien été mais
moi j'accumule les tiges accumulé un peu
l'énergie ping puis il ya un stress que
même sans m'en rendre compte s'est
accumulée troisième journée pour une
niaiserie madymo j'ai perdu patience et
vraiment je fais juste
la chanteuse a dit hadi acquis
j'aimerais qu'on se change pour la vidéo
puis elle avait dit dans un courriel
privé fait que je me mets tu joues et
blanc avec une petite veste par dessus
mais je trouvais que tu fais là avec la
vie sociale est sèchement ça marchait
pas c'est que le statu quo n'est que si
je mets la même veste mais un tournoi la
vo et ses bosquets lac leman parfait gg
les rockit six fois que je mets le
tee-shirt noir plus j'arrive plus je
trouve que je crache éclairer ce ben
parce que j'étais en droit mais à cause
que je t'ai commanders reste
faites le seuil serait que sa maman
l'habillement chaussures je me sens de
just dance est parfaite et super beau
mais j'avais dit paul germain changé je
demande et en tous genres non non c'est
parfait jeudi par l'agencé comme du
poignet mais à cause des sujets comme le
temps avoué dit 10.1 passive agressive
finalement plus et comme j'en étais
petit par exemple clairement tout le
match mais après c'était trop jour
d'accumulation de stress pile à cause
d'une niaiserie d'habillement qui dort
dans une communication web que le george
eastman pièce moment tac bref ça arrive
mais ferme à qui ça arrive à d'autres je
suis comme j'ai déjà on dit que c'est
juste je comprends mieux c'est quoi le
stress
comment comment que ça arrive mais j'en
laisse plus passer au ciment puis c'est
un bon point qui bat ans quand ça nous
arrive des fois les tirs où est-ce qu'on
nous doit ensemble dans notre relation
aux carnets et comme des affaires qui a
crush gens ont besoin d'un espèce de ces
cinq de nos édiles de calme un peu tanné
le petit pays comme étant des courses
connaître si on est capable comme
vraiment de désamorcer sort rapidement
de centres sans en discuter vraiment le
mieux quand ça arrive avec quelqu'un que
tu fais n'est pas tant que sur ces
jusqu'à demain un espèce de build up de
chute le plus comme une espèce
d'ambiance de marbre qui s'installe puis
tu sais quand tu es capable de voir ce
puits on en parle aussi avec guillaume
dulout de près le tipi ne faire qu il on
a besoin de bâtir notre relation de
confiance de discussions pourraient
faire parler ce sujet l'outil site e pas
cette relation-là de conversation avec
quelqu'un ou de communication mais peut
pas vraiment aborder ce sujet loeb ça
fait jusqu'à moins exposé que non mais
c'était avec sonia c'était pourrais moi
c'était vraiment un des podcasts jeu au
complet le du sans-fil concurrence et
c'est drôle parce que si le podcast où
on se parle et il sort du lot
aujourd'hui quand on tourne ses podcasts
puis j'ai fait soit mis sur la demande
et au monde vous c'est quoi vos
meilleurs podcasts moments préférés
fulda monde répondait ça nul bien sûr
piquionne mais genre je pense qu'il va
vraiment être apprécié ce paquet d'amis
c'est une fille incroyable une femme
incroyable une dame magistrats et rudy
universal c'est vraiment une pro puis on
vous laisse avec un extra un extra une
extrait de sonia lupien houllier extrait
passé de stress et pour mieux faut quand
même trouver le sweet spot de stress
dans le fond oui ça me suis bien content
de parler des jeunes que je me dis si
peuvent la prendre avant et ce que je
dis toujours aux jeunes arrêtez d'avoir
peur du stress parce que c'est ce qui va
vous tuer à long terme
ce qu'on sait le plus c'est de notre
faute à nous ainsi la faute je fais mon
mea culpa c'est la faute des chercheurs
scientifiques et des médias qui depuis
que vous êtes né vont vous dire que le
stress est négatif toxiques faut
l'éviter à tout plus c'est une erreur
d'avoir fait ça pourquoi parce qu'il ya
une courbe en u inversé donc priver
cette barre le nôtre le stress et la
performance donc un peu de stress c'est
super bon ça va augmenter sa vigilance
c'est la première fois que ma fille a eu
une entrevue pour une job on jase a
atteint pme cotées partie ma soeur à dix
coups dont tu le stressé j'ai dit c'est
que son poteau et fo rsha oui mais un
certain niveau de résistance donc on a
tous un point de résistance qui est
différent le montant de ces effets
négatifs donc si tu as peur du stress à
temps plein soit à retrouver tout est un
côté négatif plus que je souffrais les
deux ans la fête du sport tas des
compétitions puis justement avant avant
le depor vous ne sommes plus stressés
c'est sûr ça va avoir un effet positif
sur ta performance mais l'effort est ce
que tous les posts trés c'est sa marque
free métro streiff et non plus je dis
souvent il ya deux catégories de gens
qui savent ce dont je parle les athlètes
parce que vous l'avez maximiser où tu
peux maximiser la performance en étant
un peu stressé et les artistes
et moi je me suis un artiste ça m'avait
dit si moins une fois dans ma vie où
j'ai pas eu le trac avant une pièce de
théâtre d'une débauche ubuntu le lac
sihwa vraiment besoin de ça mais
d'autres on pense aussi pourquoi il ya
autant d'anxiété chez les
no dans nos soldats nos écoles c'est ce
qu'on appelle la sensibilité à l'anxiété
ce que je m'explique que vous allez
reconnaître c'est quoi c'est un peu
comme la part des titres et c'est donc
anti stress et je te l'aï dit on quand
on envoie des signes comme côté stressé
donc encore bobby est et c'est comme
portefeuille aux alumineries chan ok
pour une raison qu'on savait pas trop il
ya des gens quand ils reçoivent ce
message le ils capotent
rires ça m'a un chevreuil pris dans les
phares d'une voiture qui arrive à vivre
le savent plus quoi faire et on sait pas
trop pourquoi ces gens le paniqué comme
ça devant le stress est une des raisons
c'est qu'on se rend compte
on dit qu'une épidémie nexium d'anxiété
dans les écoles cégeps enfin une des
raisons c'est j'ai pas quel âge vous
avez le maître depuis vous n'êtes ni sur
vos réseaux sociaux n'importe où on vous
dit que le stress est toxique l'éviter
et ensuite on s'étonne que quand un
petit prout qu'une réponse normale de
stress devant un examen et capotes parce
qu'il ressent qui est stressé de siège
avec ce sacre un klaxon d'encore plus le
la peur la peur du stress ou est-ce
qu'on se l'est fait en anglais ça
s'appelle des stress mindset pilotes on
se dit les jeunes faut changer les
choses en face à des prêts conception de
stress on regarde bien les athlètes êtes
vous le savez il chercheur au prix de
deux groupes de jeunes des gens qui ont
des prêts conception négative de stress
y vendra jamais bon dix trains soit
malade qui des gens qui ont des prêts
conceptions politiques et astuces etc
dans certains cas c'est bon je mesure
les hormones de stress de ces deux
groupes le les gens qui ont des prêts
conception de stress produisent plus
d'hormone de stress que ceux qui ont des
prêts conception positive
ensuite ils ont pris des gens qui
avaient des prêts conception négative et
pendant une semaine ils leur ont montré
des vidéos des effets positifs du stress
qu ils ont été capables de diminuer en
blanc et alain verte s'ils ont pris des
gens qui avaient des prix conception
positive et pendant une semaine leur ont
montré des vidéos des effets toxiques et
les gatti lui et on monte les hormones
de stress c'est pour ça que ce qu'on dit
pour ça que je suis venu aujourd'hui je
suis pas de le dire tout ce qu'on me dit
on parle aux 5 à 9
mais si je capable de leur dire ça de
dire ok la journée où tu vas comprendre
que le stress est que tout ce que tu
peux mexy miser comme performance une
fois que tu lis et puis t'as pas besoin
d'être un athlète nécessairement pour le
faire des jaloux tu voi soir été capotée
avec ça je suis tellement la fois à un
pack d'incidence qui dans la
conversation le c'est fascinant
jusqu'à ce que tu viens de dire l'espèce
de démonisation du stress c'est quelque
chose qui est omniprésent sur les
réseaux sociaux en ce moment là l'espèce
de ultra nécessairement self care mais
tns l'espèce de on enlève tous les tous
les sites récente notre ville pour pour
se recentrer sur nous mêmes
puis ça en fait c'est un peu une piste
c'est un peu un service yeux j'imagine
parce que comme tulle explique si tôt
par à ce point-là du stress créé encore
plus d'anxiété par rapport à un stress
potentiel le ca deviens qui tu commences
à paralyser de vendée a fait exactement
c'est exactement ce succès pour se
montrer mon livre s'appelle par amour du
stress les gens des fois il disait
faudrait et dit pourquoi tu écris parce
que quand tu comprends exactement
comment fonctionne la bête
c'est somme toute assez facile à
contrôler mais je pense qu on stresse
beaucoup parce qu'on sait pas comment ça
fonctionne depuis tout à prouver ça je
veux te ramener une notion que qui
s'appelle un stress relatif quand on
parle de stress juste pour finir mon
dico de stress mais sinon on va se
perdre entre choses là une dernière
notion qu'il faut prendre en compte
c'est la différence entre je les dis
qu'un cerveau détecte une menace produit
des hormones de stress
jin jing ses répliques sauf que deux
types de menaces il ya des menaces qu'on
appelle absolue c'est à dire une menace
réelle à notre survie qu'à keur rentrée
s'ils crient au feu au commencera pas
aux agents
il y en a plus belle beille de deux
semaines la copie de ses principales
menaces absolue et on est entourés de
nos jours de menaces relatives ces fonds
par litre et les chercheurs se sont
trouvés pris devant un problème et on
dit coudonc tu prends deux personnes
systématiquement et jean ni stressé du
monde dans mon la poule
il prend deux personnes qui était exposé
à la même situation stressante
systématiquement nom qui va réagir avec
une réponse de stress pilotes rien
pantoute
ça existe pour une situation stressante
pour tout le monde à moins que ça soit
menaçante nationale et donc les
chercheurs se sont dit ok mais il doit
avoir des caractéristiques d'une
situation qui vont faire que peu importe
qui tu es large que tout la job que toi
tu bosses tracy ont cherché soit pendant
20 ans et ils sont arrivés à découvrir
les quatre caractéristiques dont je
parle tout le temps pour voir où je m'en
vais avec ceux ayant montré qu' il faut
qu'une situation et une ou plusieurs de
botté d'envoi les cas depuis un an a
baissé de 6,4 caractéristiques là pour
que ton cerveau détecte une menace
produisent une réponse de stress faut
que la situation soit nouvelle faut
qu'elle soit imprévus ou imprévisible
faut peut-être l'impression et sur le
site n l'impression de taper le contrôle
de la situation et ça doit il menaçant
pour ton égo en quelqu'un qui remet en
question la capacité de faire ta job
devant dumont le petit fils inc est
aussi seule réponse le stress est
toujours ces quatre looks toujours les
cas le poteau et quand je te mets au
défi de trouver mon arrive mans avec
n'importe quel stress heures le
chauffeur comme gregory charles qui
devait arriver moi qui la choque mais
moi je te je m'attèle déconstruire on va
voir ça fait sept ans que les chercheurs
ont cherché le cinquième set il était
capable d'aller le chercher avec ça fait
que c'est pour ça qu'on stress parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de nouveautés et
prévisibilité pout pout de cible mais
pas il si ton cerveau il est capable de
produire une réponse de stress devant
des caractéristiques comme ça tu te
rends compte à quel point tu du pouvoir
sur ton stress relatif si tu changes ta
façon de voir les choses
si tu changes ce qui est imprévisible
petit habitués à cette imprévisibilité
les hétéros tu arrêtes de capoter avec
la nouveauté
tu va envoyer le message attention aux
expos de manas peau il va arrêter de
produire des donc on a beaucoup plus de
contrôle qu'on pense
[Musique]
hier c'est noir barque s'est-elle
extraits sélectionnés en plus elle
en plus d'être la personne qui connaît
le plus le sujet genre sur la terre
presque lüthi est vraiment faux ni
l'état enfin les rôles qui est
extrêmement bonne communicatrice fin
là c'était impeccable parlant de bonne
de bon communicateur les personnes qui
connaît mieux on a eu c'est vraiment de
petites des fois on est quand même
vraiment pro sur le timing était
dernièrement le fait avec noémie vincent
ou est ce qu il venait de sortir daudet
l'heure de vérité c'était la veille
qu'on était comme les premiers sur le
web qui sont pas dans l'espèce de de
microcosme de nouveaux puits de produits
laitiers parce que lyon fait évidemment
tournée des médias
deux de ces boîtes le puits après ce nom
était comme les premiers jets qui sont
venus laitiers puis jeté comme un scoop
mais mais une des fois où est ce qu'on a
fait ça c'était vraiment pitié le site
un peu bat de parler de scoop en parlant
de ce sujet là parce que c'était suite à
la mort de claude plomb cydia qui
fraudent magna une grosse affaire qui se
passe aux states en ce moment puis il
faut qu'on appuie faut qu'on en parle
c'est le black-out valence est trop
important fait qu'on a invité webster et
dimanche fête le dimanche je le disais
je pense que georges tron avait été
assassiné le vendredi si je ne trompe
pas où le samedi on ces deux jours là le
dimanche j'ai dit et webster y est j'ai
dit aymen soit est en demande beaucoup
fait qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient disposés
sur une prochaine fois et j'ai aucune
entrevue planifié tu peux me lundi matin
on se rend compte on vient au studio
funky plus qu'on a réalisé ce qu'il est
les médias traditionnels ne travaille
pas le dimanche est avec nous ses vannes
au stress planes écrit lundi matin
les girls at et fort je prenne une pause
là où deux parents votre podcast parce
que j'ai comme des appels avec des
débits radio kings est venu s'asseoir
ici à fait légaux mars
mais n'est dit vous avez été les
premiers 10 mais aujourd'hui lama
semaine et bouquets mur à eelv a reçu 58
le lundi matin pour des entrevues fait
que may a été extrêmement généreux de
son temps petit c'est quelqu'un qui est
tellement au courant de l'histoire des
noirs en amérique ou en occident fait le
tir puis c'était steyn qui se fait
grandiose conversation c'était dans
c'était pile au point au moment où est
ce qu'il y avait au pricing
aux états unis où est-ce que ici on ne
parlait que de ce public comme une
référence extrêmement précises puis
extrêmement qualifiés pour nous en
parler c'était au temps nestea
oui vraiment c'est parce que justement
comme si le timing est idéal des pistes
et la personne parfaite pour mettre un
événement d'actualité tir qui vient
littéralement juste d'arriver dans un
contexte beaucoup plus large peut-être
comprendre c'est quoi le racisme d'où ça
vient d'où
depuis combien de temps ça existe
pourquoi ça existe qui sait ce mois-ci
cepralmar le podcast team et on dit je
peux qu'on subisse des flops considère
qu'elle peut cogner incroyable et il met
aussi une chose entre guillemets
important que le petit con qu'on a fait
pour moi d'avoir sorti à ce moment là
puis ça va vraiment y penser les
extraits les plus partagés c'est
littéralement la journée du quai c'était
le black-out tuesday nautical avait
partagé ses sa pitié vraiment parce que
c'est pas parce que y cremailh a été
écouté c'est juste parce que j'ai
l'impression qui écrit mon num contribué
quelque chose nokia à mettre l'épaule à
la roue d'un changement dans la bonne
direction s'est fait que c'était
vraiment cool pitié où j'ai écouté un
petit peu après cet épisode le jeu
tellement typique encore une fois je
suis sur le cul des connaissances puis
des deux thomas mois les buttes qui me
fascine le plus c'est comme à
l'esclavagé le racisme est indissociable
de l'histoire des états unis oui mais
aussi de l'américain général pi de
l'europe cpie disent pourquoi tu y mets
ton l'europe depuis 500 ans est devenu
comme l'espèce de
de référence ou de l'emblème de
supériorité intellectuelle d'innovation
du ce c'est sur le dos des africains sur
le dos des autochtones sur le dos de
l'esclavagé parce que c'est comme ceux
qui sont devenus économiquement
supérieur
c'est ce qui a permis après ce temps
d'autres innovations c'est ce qui s'est
vraiment mis au centre de tout l'été
l'économie mondiale tilke l occident sur
l'espèce de deux milieux de 200 du monde
de de tout ce type ici vraiment
grotesque leur esclavage puis 10 pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas se dissocier
des histoires là parce que si même si
mettons pilule esclavage au québec mais
même si il y en a plus
par exemple autant que cette usine ebay
et dhiba et il leur homme qui est acheté
ou le succès d'acheter un outil d'une
doute on exportait digitimes et j'ai
entendu ce matin dans pas de cash
demande si les télés morue qu'on
compense en gaspésie ce kit est pas
belle mauvaise qualité
je suis persuadé que comme nourriture
aux esclaves affectés
cc c'est plus large que juste au regard
des acquis à cet endroit le précis et
vêtus de l' esclavage c'est tout un
modèle sismique systèmes concurrents ce
qui explique l influence même jusqu'à en
asie que ça avait c'est vraiment sur
toute la planète que ça lui en un fleuve
puis si aujourd'hui
ici on a une bonne qualité de vie en
général on est des moyens mais sa course
qu'on a hérité de cet avantage le mais
il y en a d'autres ont payé tout à fait
j'irai peut-être chercher un extrait
justement voit ce qu'est ce que nous
explique c'est beaucoup mieux que ce qui
fait on va l'écouter se règle extraits
extraits avant la la traite
transatlantique se doit d'aller chercher
des africains pour les amener en
esclavage dans les amériques
l'économie de l'europe était
sensiblement la même que un peu partout
sadirac qu'en amérique chez les
autochtones ou les africains c'est à
dire
les terres agricoles les échanges
étaient donc on avait un cri culture les
échanges etc
donc ya pas de méga plantations en
europe à partir du moment où est-ce
qu'on a pris des africains qu'on a placé
sur la terre des autochtones et qu'on a
développé toutes ces terres là en méga
plantations pour faire du sucre 1 pour
faire de l'indigo pour faire la tête sur
bleu pour faire le scot dont le tabac le
cacao
eh bien ça propulsé l'europe
tout l'argent l'or et l'argent qui
venait d'aymen hammed du sud vers
l'espagne
tous ces ressources premières qu'on
amenait des élastiques guadeloupe
bahamas et chirac ont amené vers
l'angleterre qu'on a mené vers la france
qui contribuait à une grande partie de
l'économie et ces marchés-là de ses
colonies étaient des marchés captifs
c'est à dire que la colonie au poste
choix d'acheter ces produits finis de la
métropole donc admettons t en nouvelle
france du bonnet serment acheter des
choses autre part qu'en france et tu
peux pas revendre dans matières
premières autre part qu'en france au
rythme où la france le voeu que ça c'est
pour tout l'est toute l'ailé les
colonies ce qui a poussé entre les
treize colonies à se rebeller toi et qui
est devenu les états unis parce que les
redevances aussi été exorbitant
oui c'est ça gérer la métropole
s'arrange comme un peu parce que
l'importance de nourrir la métropole la
colonie sert à nourrir
économiquement la métropole et donc on a
une amérique qui est un marché captif de
l'europe en afrique dans la force
humaine est ponctionnée pour cultiver
ces matières là et donc ça propulsé
l'europe économiquement et
technologiquement aussi
et toi à ce moment là les européens
voulaient changer avec la chine le japon
et ses erreurs mais voulait rien savoir
parce que les européens n'avaient rien
qui intéressait la chine et le japon et
donc les esclavages et cetera
c
pillage des ressources a permis une
avancée technologique qui une fois
arrivés en chine une fois arrivé au
japon juste eu à forcer militairement
ces marchés là pour échanger toi et donc
même toute cette histoire du monde
atlantique une incidence jusqu'à nazis
tu vois jusqu'à là jusqu'à là jusqu'à la
chine jusqu'au japon
et donc cette prééminence occidentale
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle a les deux
pieds trempés dans l' esclavage des 500
dernières années et ça on peut pas le
l'extirper de ça parce que sinon ça
record une vision très eurocentrée désir
bambins l'europe de par son génie s'est
hissé au dessus des autres comme deux
nuls pas toi mais quand on analyse on se
rend compte que c'est sur les puits sur
la tête des africains des autochtones
qui a le l'europe pu jouer ce rôle dans
les derniers siècles
et donc c'est pour ça que quand on parle
de foot alité policières quand on parle
de privilèges quand on parle tout ce qui
se passe en ce moment pour moi doit
automatiquement le ramener à l'histoire
des 500 dernières années me christophe
colomb toi te dirai mettre la situation
canada au québec versus celle aux etats
unis c'est quoi la différence psycho les
ressemblances
bah tu vois ça dépend de quelle approche
on prend cette version on parle de
l'esclavagé aux états unis les slaves
acheter un esclavage des plantations en
esclavage économique tandis qu'ici c'est
un esclavage domestique
c'est des gens qui étaient dans les
maisons qui servaient des repas et chez
terreur parce que on n'avait pas le
climat
pour avoir des plantations mais si on
avait eu plus moi bien sûr qu'on aurait
fui parce que j'ai les mêmes gens qui
venaient ici et elles mêmes gens qui
partaient en martinique qui partait en
guadeloupe haïti et donc on pense
toujours que notre histoire est
tellement différente mais
oui des différences mais des similitudes
aussi dans les mentalités d'époque et je
regarde juste ce qui se passe avec les
autochtones aussi les violences
policières qui ont la vue à rouen il ya
quelques années envers les femmes
autochtones en eau propre dynamique de
racisme ici et je veux dire faut être
conscient que les amériques ont été
construites sur le racisme
qu'est ce qui a donné à partir du moment
où des européens se sont donné le droit
de s'installer sur les terres
autochtones qui voit et se taire comme
étant libre pendant il y avait des gens
évitent des toits mais à partir du
moment où est ce qu'ils se sont dit on
peut venir ici parce que ce sont des
terres vierges
c'est que à partir de ce moment là tu
considère ces gens pas comme des humains
mais ces gens ils ont le même droit que
le chevreuil dans la forêt loi et donc
nos histoires sont ancrés dans le
racisme mais le racisme au l'a extirpé
d'une trame historique que ce soit au
canada jeudi aux etats-unis c'est plus
difficile de l'extirper ici ça a été
plus facile de l'extirper parce que il y
avait une moins grande population noire
entre audi souvent on pense au racisme
blanc noir mais il ya le racisme envers
les autochtones aussi qui est qui qui
est très présent et donc au final notre
histoire aussi est trempé là dedans je
vous donne un exemple aussi que je
trouve fera pas c'est quand tu vu la
blague fils avec justin excusez moi je
disais non ce n'est pas une histoire
québécois semaines histoire canadienne
le black fils aux états unis si vous
allez dans les journaux à partir de 1842
jusqu'à 1900 vous allez dans le daily
mercredi à québec que vous allez dans la
monture herald
il ya des annonces de black fait c'est
pratiquement chaque mois il y avait des
concerts de blackface ici au théâtre
royal notamment au music hall à québec
il y avait du blackface pratiquement à
chaque mois chaque année on retrouve des
instances de gens qui vont sale con du
blackface mais pourtant on nous dit non
monsieur bonnes histoires d'ici de la
personne
posez les nationales calixa-lavallée
faisaient du bloc face aux etats unis
une carrière de blake face aux états
unis et donc on a une grande millau pis
historiquement ici judicieusement envie
de parler d' aveuglement
reparlons de myopie pour l'instant
[Rires]
[Musique]
cette année 1 des highlights de mon
année on arrête de ma vie franchement
c'est d'avoir rencontré daniel bélanger
quelle légende c'est de loin le podcast
que j'avais pour lequel il était le plus
stressé avant d'annoncer depuis qu'on a
commencé les podcasts j'étais stressée
je savais pas comment ça allait aller
parce que la libé l'enjeu de l'entente
très très rarement en longues entrevues
ou en entrevue points
je ne sais pas si elle est généreux de
ses réponses je sais pas si ça lui
tentait d'être si le tribunal il y avait
l'air de vouloir revenir là dessus on
n'a pas tordu aucun bras personnes
mais la seconde qui rendra le studio
tout ceci est tombé tout le stress est
tombée hier entre et a fait ouais je
prendrai peut-être
t puis j'ai comme proposé un math et
bien fait un matin surmonter ma pile et
on a compris qu eric et ses jardins
relation la discussion là qu'on va voir
si parfaite puis comme de fait la
conversation il y aura ce thème
on dirait que j'ai une falaise même pas
une semaine pendant le podcast pour
réaliser qu'on est en train de parler à
footing daniel bélanger que j'ai écouté
toute ma vie c'est vraiment un des
artistes j'écoutais le plus de ma ville
et tient pendant que sur ma tombe
si si je te regarde et regrouper tous
mais tous mes atouts mais itunes mais
apporte podcast depuis mai tout seul je
serai à rennes me donne puis daniel
bélanger mettons le les deux shows
objecté le plaisant ma ville et subit
pas vraiment lié mais comme une légende
vivante puis fin je me pince pendant
toute l'épreuve casse nous raconter les
anecdotes mois encore une fois l'extrait
qu'on avait mis sur sur instagram aussi
là on dirait que c'est la mère anecdotes
qu'on va raconter toute ma vie possible
c'est la chose qui fait tellement le
quai après avoir fait une résidence au
spectrum de trois semaines sold out
pendant trois semaines à plat de sortir
puis pape et les bouteilles même de
débloquer avec sac où il prenait son
vélo il descend d olaf leur poignée de
drogue une patate puis ça c'était son
seul c'est la meilleure anecdote ça
pourrait pas être une anecdote qui fait
de plus avec l'image que j'avais de
daniel bélanger avec la personne qu'on
avait devant nous ouais allons vraiment
y ce n'est que d'autres lycées comme
c'est vraiment un petit temps je trouve
pas ça bouge chez moi c'était ma manière
de vivre leur style est la chose la plus
grandiose le système quand le fait
d'aller manger mon due à des steaks
hommes y avait rien dans un lycée
je venais de vivre un triomphe libye
après ça je revenais dans ce que j'ai
été pour vrai street de hot-dogs puis
après ce tir on en a connu un autre
moment après of kain - est-ce qu il
parlait d'aller chercher sa fille julia
tons or sur le podcast aussi pileux
nicole ya comme dit est ce que on se
revoit parce que lille revenait pour
pour jay du stand ce que de la semaine
d'après je pense
planer comme dirait qu'on se revoie play
et du tout si tu fais comme nicole exact
yaté au défunt que je préfère un julien
tu attends un peu jeté entraîne un
fermier il ya trop la fin lapin
premièrement il y avait agi comme des
fiefs à son drôle donne un peu sympa et
relancer pitois denis cas depuis le
début on a fait le nikon mêlant drake
c'est devenu tellement réel quand ces
cités qui loge au studio qui est des
comme nicole planté là mais non mais non
c'est pas ça marche ça m'arrive souvent
que quel monde en fait ils sont comme si
jamais c'est vraiment ton vrai nom c'est
ma foi comme a réagi parce que justement
astor que je me présente je me présente
comme système mon vrai nom j'ai eu
aucune difficulté à rester sérieux si
j'adore j'adore que toi tu as la remuer
les malaises que même nous parce que je
me suis beau joe amon air de fête manon
sinico l'eau sont non c'est juste le
sting joe cole et hélène colle déjà
goûté l'annoncé nikon excuse moi j'ai
dit à chantereyne pizza dans les
podcasts des jo s'il ya un moment à un
moment donné ou si il le fait dans votre
podcast ce site qui vous c'est qu'il
devait recevoir anglais plein essor
comme se basera micro et two way lady
dans picasa avec giffa c'est la deuxième
fois que nick alimentaire
j'ai vraiment il est vraiment faux ni
justement comme suit les grilles 0000
jamais senti que je parlais a
probablement le musicien le plus
populaire du québec des derniers 20 ans
ces puits lui-même tiffany funny joke
avec selex peux pas croire que je te
mène faire des gags cas c'est vraiment
c'était vraiment en plus d'être drôle et
inspirante et de parler un gone même
comment qui travaille comme mon kiki
moi qui fait sa musique est de plus en
plus lui même comme un ticket com qui
composent que moi qui écris moi ça m'a
vraiment inspirée levrat de rencontrer
un génie comme cela s'est si bien
raconter quelque chose ou si je pense
sur le podcast de jay par contre il
raconté mais quand tu t'en vas voir sur
et les descriptions de c'est tout nous
mettons les petites voix lui qui a fait
leur castration c'est comme achille
quelque chose piste un nom qui revient
quand même
puis tu penses que c'est comme un
collaborateur articles ceux qui
travaillent souvent avec daniel bélanger
que tout mais c'est son alter ego c'est
lui même qui fait les orchestrations et
tout mais c'est juste quelqu'un qui
quand daniel bélanger trop occupé
il délègue la chine quelque chose c'est
bon il racontait ce qu'on sait c'est
exceptionnel n'est ce pas ce qui est
pire puisqu'on sait pas c'est que
achilli habitants su expliquer c'est
comment elles se comptent pourtant sûr
l'accord entrera 52 des mélanges effet
une cm par chanson mais h et vient en
fait 14 mai mon frère et deux comtés qui
est aimé ton cinéma c'est arrivé très je
pense que j'ai passé jean marc vallée
qui fait tellement plein d'affaires sur
ces films team et on y fait le montage
il fait que mettons des fois je t'aime à
à certains postes
il met un autre nom parce que dit il le
faudrait que générique vous des films je
vais juste mon nom partout le fait qu'il
m'était m'étais dit je t'aime maladie de
lyme pourtant pas avoir la du gain qui
fait tout son fils aîné qui est bonne
avec donne en vrai qu'un extrait de ce
pôle quel est le degré ou la flore
d'être le dindon la forme même si c'est
lui qu'on a émis sur instagram je pense
que c'est bon quand même le fait qu' on
pourra écouter un extrait oye est ce qu
est ce que dans ces années là
est ce que tu as vécu ton rock si oui
mais c'est parce que l'image que j'ai de
daniel bélanger c'est quelqu'un est
quand même introverti qu'elle a jeté 10e
devant toi corrigez moi si je me trompe
mais ce quelqu'un quand même introverti
qui rentre à l'hôtel après son spectacle
pour pour se coucher pipi se lever le
lendemain puis recommencez de façon
assez méthodique
oui oui c'est un peu ça pendant le
sommet mais ce que j'aime vivre mon rock
mais il me le jem l'inventer mort quand
j'ai fait la résidence au spectrum
pendant trois semaines après qu'elle lui
a des fois mettons kimchi pas les soirs
par semaine ne pourront pas dire de
bêtises je partais du spectrum et puis
je m'en allant charmant j'ai un bon deux
c'est trop dur dogues ne pas taxer 1127
l'échangeur surcouche et la flore riches
les collèges ans à côté le team entier
de connaître un triomphe
finalement il triomphait le poids des
bouteilles de champagne
2 1 aux lames un très bon duo la place
des jeunes sont au top pour moi je
restais ce que j'ai été avec les rêves
que j'avais pu je revenais me your dog
et
c'était très spécial pour moi c'est par
que je fais sans me tromper
un bon gros show ou même temps je suis
pas très apportée voire la meilleure
bouteille devant aller manger ça peut
arriver mais je suis plutôt j'aime
j'aime le contraste ça fait d'aller
terminer saut avec quelque chose pour
moi de très rock là dedans et à ma
mesure sam si c'est à moi ça me fait
triper très très fort d'abord les deux
d'avoir un gros succès puis après ça
revenir ce que j'aime le plus de ce que
je fais cette stricte un peu inquiète
il n'aurait pu manger moins noble pays
je serai fier ça me fait peur face
andrietti les shows les plus pressantes
[Musique]
oui bon on va se pencher wangen au nez
cassé comptant un temps je n'ai pas de
casque et aubin et mail qu'on n'a pas
déjà parlé ben je vous le savez déjà
mais c'est pas ma question ça on est là
c'est le trotter toutes les émissions
que tu vois tes mais toutes les
entrevues avec toi tu es ville c'est
toujours ceux qui bavent voyons donc ce
n'est pas cette histoire le 15 pour ça
que les choses ce n'est que rien n'est
plus tellement du mifa lancé 15 mois
deux à écouter tellement que ça paraît
qu'une entrevue santé de jimmy fallon ch
pas capable mais n'importe quoi mais
pourtant qu'il ya des podcasts qui sont
ici que c'est qu'un peu bref royan dont
ben c'est comme mettre toute sa vie des
jeunes
si je retourne hamid et puis je disais
ouais parce que maintenant on est on est
seul web
j'ai le temps d'y penser qu' il ya plein
de portes qu'à ce que j'ai tripé mais
j'en écoute calment en même temps que je
peux capable de parler de toutes ces
podcasts loti mathon leur antre sur coup
j'ai vraiment vraiment tripé mais je
pourrais pas dire en particulier qu'est
ce qui me frappe et il était à ce point
ici dix mois plus tard parce que laurent
turcot ses débuts 2020 et puis si elle
est aussi en mars d'abord de
l'impression d'avoir trompé comme un
tabernacle
il m'appelle comme pas exactement ce
qu'on a parlé directement impliqué on en
parle peu de temps tout l'avant après
n'ont même pas de casque hi mais reste
en tête moi ces cassandre bouchons je la
connaissais pas tant que
je suivais pas trop ce qu'elle faisait
mais dans ce podcast là on a vraiment
remis remis en question tout milite et
dudu coupe comme on reconnaît là parce
qu'on en a parlé qu'il y avait de plus
en plus et d'infidélité tout ce les
couples ouvert que ça devient de plus en
plus en mode qui est ce on a quand même
remis en question tout cette notion le
petit mois après sa mort en fait
réfléchir c'est quelque chose qui me
reste en tête relève vraiment c'est
clair et qui puis quand vous commandez
un petit peu or quand totti c'est
quelque chose qui au début on faisait
sur beaucoup dans le podcast recevait du
monde avec aucune idée de quand on leur
parle et puis des fois c'est donner des
bonnes conversations des fois ça donne
et des moins bonnes conversations mais
avec cassandre effectivement et comme
tombe dit parce qu'elle est et où elle
était ouverte par rapport aux faits
qu'elle avait trompé son ex puis on en
avait parlé puis à m'en parler
ouvertement
puis si on est tombé dans le débat
serait d'applaudir ou est-ce qu'on a
nous même parler de nos expériences ou
est ce que dit ce genre de podcasts
laisse tout le temps gordon cancer et
yves l'éthique un contentement
quinconces où quelqu'un juste parce qu
ce parce qu'on sait qu'on a un bon
moment parlé avec la pression tombe dans
dans quelque chose de difficile
c'est comme on dit on touche pas de
castéra or au podcast le métier 2019
on n'allait plus souvent dans dans le
personnel justement dans les relations
que le jeu a pensé entre antoine olivier
pilon le sujet dont on parle c'est quand
même un petit peu mais on tombe
rapidement dans les cours adultes
routine femme claudia bouvette on avait
une tombe est plus dense et c'était le
pks les cassandre ont 2020 c'est un
souhait ce qui est vraiment tout le
monde s'y tient pouvait on peut parler
ces expériences il ya eu les listes a
été un motif des beautés qui s'était
vraiment c'était vraiment beau pétrin
des conversations justement t as many je
me souviens on a fait les le sondage de
kiki dans cette pièce a déjà été
tranchée ou des jeux tron 75 % 15 %
parce que c'était juste tout est nickel
qui avait jamais vécu cinq ans qu'on
était de 75 c'était celle ci ne sera
jamais la cuistrerie pur non mais t'es à
quel point
ces coureurs notamment plus et lights
puis d'ajouter je diablement qui sont
trompés ou le monde qui trompe aussi
pitié c'est des choses qui arrivent
c'est la vie pitre ici s'il faudra pour
en parler de façon ouvert sans jugement
aussi noter enfin que oui c'était
vraiment cette belle rencontre qui
tendrait plutôt à le consulter les avec
un peu l'été d'après the great personnes
oui vraiment films pour toute l'année
vraiment je me rappelle aussi qu on
avait je pense est la première fois qu
on avait abordé un peu les toute la saga
en 10 ans ce qui est vraiment ici testé
ce pas intéressant c'est aussi le pit et
sans jugement le pister non c'était
vraiment un bon point de casser quelque
chose c'est quelque chose qui mettons là
on en avait parlé de ça pue on avait
juste eu la conversation ti puis on
n'avait pas nécessairement proposions me
rappelle ma position est encore pas
arrêté sur ces choses le titre encore
ambivalents mais je trouve que peut-être
que je m'éloigne du podcast un petit peu
mais je trouve que d'avoir de se donner
le droit d'avoir des conversations c'est
ça manque qu'à la société en ce moment
j'ai l'impression qu'en ce moment là tu
parles on en parlait hier avec avec les
andes demande nicole puis juste d'avoir
le droit de discuter d'un sujet d'un
sujet qui de sujets d'actualité un sujet
walk que ce soit le moment et en nous
que ce soit les dénonciations que ce
soit et que ce soit justement on ifans
est ce que c est ce que c'est si c'est
correct d'encourager ce titre juste est
ce qu'on peut mais ton si moi je lève la
main ça y est j'ai mon opinion sur une
femme n'est pas arrêtée encore gelé
dialyse en qui ont un iphone j'en ai
parlé beaucoup de ces puits mon opinion
n'est pas arrêtée sur ce mais est ce
qu'on peut en parler puis le fait que je
veux en parler puis j'amène des bémols
est ce que ça fait de moi l'ennemi à
abattre non non ce métier tu vois le le
sujet le thème dont il parle là c'est
exactement ce que je voulais parler du
process de laurent turcot parce qu'on ne
parle exactement de soins
disait mon opinion est arrêté sur rien
sur aucun sujet et tout le temps
constante évolution
puis justement tire quand c'est pas
parce qu'on s'exprime sur quelque chose
parce que j'étais chaud dans un podcast
le si beau que je suis encore d'accord
le kef ce que j'ai dit que mon opinion
et est arrêté métier faut avoir la
discussion pouvoir cheminer puis avancez
et pitié fait que ça coince et sophie
deux on va aller écouter un des segments
sur les coupes
j'imagine qu'on parle avec casse en
europe on reviendra pour la suite avec
laurent turcot
quel pourcentage pensée de personnes qui
soient vont vivre vont commettre
l'adultère soit le le de la génération y
vivre mais mettons de la génération
maintenant à vous je bosse 75 % c'est
une bonne question mais alex pense
vraiment beaucoup là c'est moi y est
tellement qu'ils m'ont écrit après cette
double pour madden et genre j'ai vécu ça
ou je les fais puis georges me sentais
tellement mal putté jeu merci d comme
d'en parler et puis de nous dire comment
tu te sens tu il ya tellement monde six
fois quel point il est facile
est-ce que celle tonnes de revoir de
revoir le couple s'était rendu à avoir
un pourcentage de 75% qui vont à
l'encontre de la vision traditionnelle
du peuple situe le temps de leur bon
j'aurais jamais pensé forcé trois
disques blu ray non être toi de ton
comme ça va tenir de même je t'aurais
honnêtement je me serais chier tu as
caché touchera et mettre un coup je me
serais rechi tuteuré georges torrès
vraiment beaucoup
deux chiens de remettre l'accouchement
il requiert je m'étais je suis vraiment
une fille qui prend le coupe classique
ne tire pas une fille qui prend les
coups plus ouvert sur ces plateformes
comme ce soit était fait
je suis mitigé parce que parce que c'est
ça fait pas partie mais pour moi le fait
de verser
deux personnes peu importe quel sexe qui
s'aiment pays qui ils veulent partager
justement tous ensemble et dans
l'intimité c'est parce que c'est arrivé
une fois que non non ne crois pas que
c'est possible
c'est peut-être là septembre quelque
chose je pose non non vraiment pas c'est
moi je sais qu'avec mon copain ça allait
juste pas très bien et il fit s'excusant
raymond ges le mais je pense pas que
j'en ferais jamais seule fac mais je
pense qu'il ya un bon questionnement
avoir par rapport à ça parce qu'il ya
tellement de plus en plus de couples
ouvert de coupe qui caisse alors dérange
pas autrui que justement il se destine
mois le nombre de personnes à qui j'ai
parlé de kunduz moi je crois pas qu'on
peut aimer une personne en est vite ces
fous pareils que les mentalités au
niveau du couple change tellement
[Musique]
elle oui bah ouais mais continue ce que
tu disais par rapport à l'épisode avec
laurent turcot en fait qu'ils étaient
des bus 2020 puis qui était probablement
le premier épisode réellement le premier
un des premiers épisodes vraiment qu'on
pourrait appeler sans dire universitaire
qu'on pourrait appeler de avec une
espèce de rigueur intellectuelle le
mettons en a déjà eu par le passé mais
céleste est le premier os qui est
vraiment c'est un expert dans un sujet
qui vient nous parler de son sujet puis
quitte ton prof à l'université picketty
qui qui ai qui expose de façon
magistrale
certains aspects j'ai dit c'est le
meilleur que je peux essayer de trouver
que l'appellation de ce genre d'épisode
le qu'on ne refait par la suite avec
sonia lupien par exemple mais c'était
vraiment un des premiers c'est un les
exemples de personnes si justement qui
qui comme le parfait ta vie tu étais pas
sa maîtrise du sujet impeccable grand
communicateur c'est vraiment facile tu
es tu poses une question petits pas
pendant 20 minutes parce qu'ils ont
travaillé fort c'est vraiment c'est ceci
est clairement dans les podcasts piste
est justement l'idée t on parlait de d'à
quel point tu es les opinions sont
polarisées beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux broutilles chez les chroniqueurs
me tonti pour nous parler un peu de ce
type de crime car le qui carbure aux
clés qui est à la pomme qui justement à
la controverse parce que c'est ce qui
crée de l'engagement c'est ce qui fait
rire les deux pit c'est le contraire
d'une réflexion puis dans un dialogue
cccd sur simplifier tout parce qu'en
réalité c'est tous les enjeux dont on
parle ici il ya rien qui est simple
c'est d'ailleurs pillot rien qui est
claire rien qui est arrêté iriez que
rien qui est noir ou blanc et xi
inquiets qui dichotomique les rings
celui qui pisse excessivement difficile
de parler de tout les sujets dans toute
son éventail de nuances et parce que
c'est extrêmement complexe pitié même le
même là souvent on s'entend mais
d'autres des causes sociales on va
s'entendre sur le point où on veut
arriver c'est bon on veut tous un monde
où est ce qu est une femme je marchais
dans la rue puissance et en sécurité
on fait tout un monde ce n'est pas tous
mais on s'entend que l'extrême grande
majorité on veut tous atteindre ce temps
on veut tous un monde puis le cas jeudi
tous les tons mauves de 95 m on veut
tous un monde où est ce que justement
dans les médias du monde représentée de
façon équitable
on fait tous un monde voit ce qui fait
peur à battre dans la rue pour la
couleur de ta peau on veut tout se vaut
tout environnement losc est il vraiment
une égalité une vraie égalité entre les
hommes les femmes peu aimé que tu veux
aussi qu'ils vivent harmonieusement avec
avec c'est aussi parce que même des
chroniqueurs de considérer de droite
[Musique]
veulent surtout lutter c'est juste que
l'on s'entend pas souvent sur une ligne
sur les masses sur la manière sur les
technicalité puis c'est le début il prit
plus souvent dans les techniques qualité
que sur le fond parce qu'en réalité les
êtres humains je te maquilles qu'on se
parle pas savoir et ce pendant deux
heures on y souvent 90 % d'accord vit
10% pas d'accord pisser mais on focus là
dessus puis justement les réseaux
sociaux en ce moment
pis la manière dont l'information ti
avec la crise des médias du ce et
véhicules et ça favorise une
polarisation qui pis est l' inverse
justement de ce qu'on essaie de faire
ici c'est inverse de ce que je pense
qu'on devrait faire en tant que société
le dialogue
puylaurens et thirteen
[Musique]
il parlait il a donné comme exemple il y
avait eu il y avait des bars utile ben
ami avec maladresse ils s'épient qu'il
te y ont eu des discussions le temps à
priver quand même animé sur mettons cela
ait un qui choque les deux s'entendent
sur l'idée sur l'idéal mais s'entendent
pas sur la manière mais ton de critiquer
ou de percevoir si tu mets ton cette
oeuvre le ses collègues pythie j'prends
le manque dans cet échange le qui était
cordiale qui étaient ouverts qui était
juste de personnes qui veulent dialoguer
pour que c'est de comprendre le point de
vue le choc les deux ont été gagnants
finalement notre échec à élever l'autre
et vice versa
même si peut-être qu'à la fin ils sont
pas entendus c'est correct oblige
toujours s'entendre sur tout mais faut
être capable de dialoguer des cantons du
moment qu demi qu'on est fermée
complètement fermé à entendre la
position en crimée adverse puisque
encore une fois peut-être même pas si
elle verse que ce puits où on perd on la
considère illégitime ou dangereuse peut
pas avoir un débat de société le temps
peut pas vraiment quoi puis mocheté à
javron sur le long terme c'est
contre-productif de faire sauter je
pense poker je pense pas que ses
camarades dans certains des baux
certaines idées retint aux opinions
tabou au point que que ce qui fait juste
verger appuyer certaines idées tt tt en
l'infréquentable je pense pas qu'il soit
la manière ou est ce que qu'on voit
ensemble prié assis parce que moi je
pense que maintenant qu'on veut
progresser le mieux c'est
soudés ensemble pour diviser je pense
qu'ils en fait en ce moment mais ton
dans l'est
la société dans laquelle on vit un des
meilleurs exemples d'une technicalité
sur lequel on passe bien trop de temps
sur la question du racisme systémique
tu es dans ce sens on est conscient
qu'il ya du racisme dans la société qui
est sûre quelle forme ça prend quelle
est la terminologie qu'on utilise
on pense bien trop de temps au tour du
sol notons passe bien trop tantôt ça
faut que tout le monde peut se
reconnaître qu'ils ont aidé la société
qui est qui qui était fondée sur le
racisme maintenant c'est quoi ta
définition du racisme systémique c'est
moi je pense que c'est un mot que j'ai
pas peur d'utiliser maintenant si tu
veux pas l'utiliser tu n'utilises pas
messi dans l'optique où est ce qu'on
pense tout la même crise à faire il faut
éradiquer sur du système peu importe
comment tu l'appelles on s'entende
c'est l'enfer c'est que souvent les gens
qui s'y opposent on la définir de
manière vraiment exagéré ses mollahs qui
fait que selon la apprécié se posent
mais à leur propre définition temps mais
je disais c'est de la semaine c'est de
la sémantique puis on passe ben d'autres
temps à parler jamais tenté il ya des
mesures pour combattre les racistes qui
ont été annoncées le pas je pensais à
québec mais aussi au provincial sous
toutes réserves récemment puiser dans le
fond cc66 ce qu'on veut c'est exact liu
arrêtons nous obstiner arrêtons de
passer des heures et des heures à
s'obstiner sur les de la technologie
utilise interne au logis ce tu veux et
tu lis la presse je veux pas si tu as
des repas mais glissions s'entend sur
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour aller de
l'avant pic pressé non comme j'apprends
qu'ils ressuscitent été témoin mais
selon mama personnel définition de ré
systémique parce que le milanais autant
que le rallye des définitions team et on
s'est juste posé la question tout
une étude désavantagé parce qu'une prise
au bâton c'était une vérité toute moitié
ce soit économiquement accès à l'emploi
accès de faire pis si la réponse est oui
ben je pense que même beaucoup de gens
qui ne refusent de prononcer les mots
racisme systémique dirais oui
ces questions c'est même sa selected ça
dérange même pas dans le fond on s'en
est créé sur un petit coin de dents dans
l'idéal une dernière chose avant qu'on
aille à un extrait de leur en turc aux
cantons le reçut le moins d'un an la
chaîne histoire nous le dira avait
quarante mille abonnés sur youtube
aujourd'hui 162 milles abonnés qui
croyable c'est une c'est la preuve que
quand tu fais de la qualité ça va être
fait comme exactement je fais la qualité
ça vole veille après le monde qui
demande le ton est un je veux partir de
la fois où met-on le monde qui nous
parlent de partir des podcasts c'est que
moi le meilleur conseil que je peux
donner c'est et c'est que ton affaire
soit de la bombe mais c'est certainement
son prix était dans l'oeil il rigoureux
y est bon il connaît bien timide qui
connaît bien étudier les causes ainsi
qu'est ce qui tue un ips mais en
reprenant de manière intelligente tina
turner et des jantes puis constants
toutes les recettes du succès au final
quand tu passes car quand et quand tu
prends mettons le même temps que tout
prix à faire un post doc sur l'histoire
de la révolution française le temps tu
prends tout ce temps devrait étudier les
codes de youtube ça se peut que tu
deviennes un pro hl fait les deux en
fait il m'a mis plus de temps sur 100 m
ça c'est pas un gros dossier une fois tu
comprennes c'était une fois que je mets
du temps la compagnie kodak écoutant cet
extrait des surcoûts extraits
tellement intéressant de mettre les
choses dans leur contexte puis on dirait
que ça sarr a su en quelque sorte où ça
ça ça peut nous des pompes et des
affaires de raison ça faisait de son
mieux comprendre ça évite de faire des
jugements rapides tient un chroniqueur
dans un journal de montréal pour nos
politicards martin lui fait des
raccourcis renée le mariage ou vendant
notre position n'est pas défendre non
mais c'est l'incarnation parfaite de
tout ce que tu veux pas dans la société
oui mais c'est vrai c'est qu'il fait un
jugement par tant de lui indépendamment
de la réalité ou d'un contexte du dit
oui mais c'est de la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle pourtant si une des
personnes les plus lus au québec
l'étude effectuée dit comment tu fais
pour te poser des gens comme ça est-ce
que tu le critique peine on se veut
devenir une cible facile
faites moi ce que je me suis dit je vais
éduquer à ma manière ou est-ce que les
gens quand ils vont travailler justement
sur l'histoire de mes poils paix dieu
sait qu richard martineau il écrit des
horreurs là dessus dit il ou non
seulement tu as un témoin patate mais ce
que tu dis est faux
- finale qui ceci est un mensonge point
final
c'est ça que je veux faire c'est pas
armé des consciences mais développer cet
esprit de doute c'est possible c'est
possible que ce soit y la fameuse
hongrie ce dont je parle est là c'est
quand tu arrives sur un sujet seaton
capacité à dire homo ou contre c'est
peut-être que tuyaux pas assez réfléchi
mois tous les sujets que l'on me
présente je le dis ok je vais écouter
mais la vérité comme tel est possible
c'est rarement semaine dans notre
société puis aujourd'hui on veut des
clips je le disais tout à l'heure
moi je rentre dans ce milieu-là des
liquides et des clips
sauf que dans les clips qui peut
apporter une nuance stuff
je me disais c'est plus compliqué que ça
mais ce qu'on pourrait éviter de
toujours une manière de le faire mais
encore une fois faut que telle
expérience des médias soit rompue à
l'expérience
puis sow mais vous le savez en plus on
en fait plus on devient bon puis plus on
fait des rares plus on est capable de
ceux de retravailler ses erreurs le plus
vous êtes capable de les voir aussi
coûte si je regarde tout ce que j'ai dit
à la radio à la télé j'en ai fait j'en
ai dit des niaiseries
puis c'est parce que je le sais que je
fais attention puis que jma mende
il ya des gens qui m'écrivent en hausse
que vous avez dit aujourd'hui il faut
avez-vous tel truc tel truc j'aime
écouter pardon je les pauvres et fait
amende honorable je ne pense pas que
charles martineau quand il écrit en
disant douter dans les patates ce que tu
dis il faut vous dire écoutez en effet
je me suis trompé on va chérir actée
dans un article si c'est la différence
entre un esprit scientifique puis ou de
l'opinion des gens vont s'exprimer sur
des feelings vous êtes un scientifique
qui va réellement capables de mettre nos
ego de côté et est heureux de se tromper
si ça peut rapprocher la vérité parce
que la laquette cpo avoir raison gagnez
des baux quoi que ce soit c'est la
recherche de vérité puis si tu t'es
trompé plus tard en contrepartie faire
amende honorable quittera pas la vérité
ou si ton collègue c'est tout tu publies
quelque chose depuis ton collègue publie
quelque chose d'autre qui répond à ce
mets tu te rends compte que c'est lui
qui a raison
ben fahd la méthode scientifique il aura
prouvé que nous devra approcher d'avir
tpiy la science aujourd'hui à pau
réponse à tout non sauf que c'est
souvent la réponse à moins fosco ne puis
il ya un élément qui dit qui est tous
très important c'est que dans l'espace
en général même dans l'espace privé
on n'a pas beaucoup de moments où on
peut changer d'opinion sur quelque chose
s'est il ya plusieurs personnes dans mon
entourage avec qui je discute de choses
en disant mon dépôt fait là dessus je
sais pas ce que j'en pense
un même tarif avec une idée tu l'as dit
tu payes cdh ont baigné de ce que je
viens de dire
mais être capable de dire écoute pense
que l'histoire de l'appropriation
culturelle
je t'aime tu peux remonter en envoyant
ce plus compliqué que ça j'en ai
beaucoup parlé avec une de mes amies
manal drissi qui me disait a dit ben non
a dit c'est comme si on racontait
l'histoire des noirs mais c'est les
blancs qu'il racontait jury mais tu sais
en histoire on essaie d'objectiver notre
subjectivité
si j'arrive avec mes affaires on sait
pas confrontés mais on a comme pour
trouver un terrain d'entente non plus
mais c'est comme une manière de dire je
sais pas si mon idée est bonne je veux
la tester avec toi qui es tu d'accord
avec sopi même tout quand tu le dis tu
fais excuses moche je viens de le dire
puis j'y crois pas je crois vraiment
première
ils fois la parole révèle le sens pour
le bon comme pour le mauvais mecs pour
ça que c'est bon tu y es tu disais tout
à l'heure le cours de français 4 où on
arrive qu'il faut exprimer nos idées
c'est très difficile d'arriver devant
tout le monde parce que ça sous-entend
qu'il faut que tout soit fini
dans ta pensée mouche désolé mais penser
n'est jamais fini si on dit cela c'est
un work in progress
puis faut se laisser cet espace est ce
que vous faites ici justement l'espace
de 10 des longs moments discussions
parce que quand tu peux juste des petits
trucs de dix minutes le moi je verrai
avec des idées qui sont ceux ultra
travail est bien fait presque fini mais
après une heure la balle haute se
rendent dans le territoire où je sais
pas trop puisqu'il fait que pour ce que
je déteste richard martineau parce que
moi je me demande aussi une opinion
tranchée sur tout je dirais tu fous toi
crise je m'aime pas sûr d'avoir un
opinion tranchée sur une seule chose
dans ma vie
[Rires]
[Musique]
chaque fois de grands crus restons dans
la même gamme de podcasts un de mes
coups de coeur en termes de personnalité
2020 ces agapes d'éviter par phil ouais
c'était durant les élections américaines
ou est-ce qu'on a reçues frédéric puis
c'était débile vente ses débuts mais
c'est un autre occasion d'un gars qui
devrait gagnon pour ce qui s'est passé
une bonne partie de sa vie à
s'intéresser tête choisi un sujet rang
précis à l'enseigné aussi à communiquer
dans l'immédiat fait les y arrivent ici
mais c'est quand même pro des pros le
puits mais ce que je sais ce qu'on
savait pas fait toni - avant qu'ils
arrivent ici ce que lui avait fait sa
thèse de doctorat en partie sur durban
donne du temps qui était sénateur pays
qui qui qui essayaient de grandir dans
le milieu politique
fake c'était la personne parfaite pour
parler des élections c'est bon
l'histoire qui le rencontrent les
français doivent comprendre français
[Rires]
puis c'était c'était un podcast
fascinante et tu vois la gueule
il connaît sa chute comme personne
après ça c'était drôle d'écouté on
écoute les dégâts sur électoral ensemble
c'est drôle de le voir lui le quai comme
c'est qui qui ponctuait t elle avec la
même vigueur rouge est crashé en
plexiglas mme ben tu vois c'est pour ce
qu'il fait c'est se situe avec la même
vigueur qu'on avec un clic et que lui
avec un qui est venu nous voir sur le
podcast une conversation motivante
inspirante puis footing intérêts sans
pitié encore une fois tim je me suis
enfin commentant sur youtube
sur cette vidéo le que je me souviens
pas c'était jamais vu un gars par les
deux hommes politiques américaines de
manière aussi impartial
c'est vrai parce que tu sais tellement
pour l'argent là la politique américaine
c'est tellement ça divise ça crée des
clans qui dit que lui-même le disait le
10 sport estime que c'est vraiment une
équipe sont selon toi tu es pour ton
équipe mardi que les autres c'est
s'aider pas bon c'est des pourris toutes
ces pilules
lui qui arrive nous ici quand même c'est
la plupart demandé en titre je tremble
au québec ne mettons pas ce que tu de
saisie des valeurs qui sont peut-être
plus éloignés de nos valeurs collectives
le moyenne ces factures fictives
nous on n'a pas la même vision de charm
que aux états unis surtout qu est
évidemment qu'un républicain et et qui
comme dans sa bulle d'information aussi
typique est qu'il est républicaine
génération en génération mais le lui
arrive avec un vraiment un regard
objectif c'est ça saastal fois parlé de
deux politiques américaines sans que ça
devienne émotif tout ça devienne à
couteaux tirés et east est vraiment
juste une analyse mais voici ce que fait
voici ce que sa présidence représente
voici ce qui pourrait arriver si réélu
c'est de manière vraiment objectif après
ce on peut tous tirer nos propres
conclusions des genres si c'est une
bonne chose ou non le tipi puis juste
avant moi ce qui m'a marqué c'est le
maintien format l'on savait pas s'il est
réélu ou non maintenant on le sait
qu'ils découvrent qu'ils approuvent à
moins que tout était une fraude épique
final je pense j'ai vu les stats c'est
sûr c'est sur ces poursuites en cours
déjà un compte 75 qui a été racheté et
il parle il parle de ce qui peut arriver
si réélu le peut-être c'est l'extrait
que choisir un put et 10,6 réélu
peut-être qu'on va voir apparaître une
dynastie de gens plus qu'apprécié avec
son fils ou sa fille son beau-fils tic y
vas tu va se présenter parce que ça va
être genre de devenir des générations
génération les chambres pour pouvoir
plus comme les bourses là on ont été ses
pieds puis 10 sa manière de faire la
politique si réélu ça va comme confirmé
que c'est une manière légitimement de
face et comme on réputé avant jeudi on
pouvait toujours se défendre
on savait pas exactement quel jour de
présidence à paraître mais là le salon
leucate allons lever 2,2 tout huit
épisodes de move un petit peu
imprévisible bel essai comme à québec
soit on n'avait plus le dessus et après
ça ça donne p17 il ya déjà d'autres nos
politiciens qui se mettent à fada
politique un peu dans les stars ce style
là puis ça peut être quelque chose qu'on
voit de plus en plus sylvie si quelqu'un
veut s'essayer le maxime bernier c'était
si farceur il a été rejeté assez
rapidement au québec
cela s appelle par accor merci mais
genre tacleur l'impression qu'on a dit
qu'on a évité
quand il semble pas me sens je pense que
2020 c'est l'année où est-ce qu'on évite
les pentes qui sentent laissés comme
bois de gauche à droite les bords le
mieux à chaque fois comme quelqu'un qui
fait d'en haut qui ramène la pente
la famille le fameux on a parlé avec
emile roux chamakhi je pense le premier
podcast de 2020 ou le douaisis la
fameuse ligne mais la dystopie lutte s
conservons une par une
on dirait qu'un accord cadre entre n2
chambranle elle dispute élections lost
et comme c'était comme l'espèce des
c'est maintenant imagine les gays et les
légats pieds ou les filles qui font du
cirque qui est qui marche sur un faire
le 10ème un genre de longs bâtons le che
super exact pour le bal le barrage
maginifique en bus bret les funambules
fait que c'est comme pour tout s'imagine
que chaque jour ce qui se passe c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a un petit pois sur un
des côtés le genre ont commencé à tendre
cole et semant à voir la gauche une
funambule commence à manquer de pied
mais le
homage to fail istanbul en bcg ce pas
rejeter mettons qu'on veut donner de
l'espoir au monde en cette fin d'année
justement pied pour venir ce qu'on
disait plus tôt j'espère que tout ce
qu'on a vécu toutes les négatifs ben ça
va me servir pour le mieux par la suite
fait convoyer jusqu'à ce jour là fallait
qu'on va aller plus dans le jeu je
trempe pas céder quelqu'un qui était
dans ma vie à tous les jours à quelqu'un
que je vois plus que je vois pas ces se
sait à quel point les médias ont tourné
la page rapidement laissé comme on le
couvre le cours ont recours aux quilles
a perdu des way vu nulle part le genre y
ait plus personne qui part de l'ue sur
mon twitter avant ce n'était que ça y'a
plus personne n'ose en parler mais dieu
avant ce n'était que ce c'est juste les
médias en général même fox news le sujet
et on le souhaite
ok mais non ferme le chapitre puis on
passe à autre chose parce qu'ils
risquent ils rendus en une journée
15 a été annoncée le sait quand on ferme
le fucking livre s est terminé dit merci
à dieu merci à fait qu'on allait voir un
extrait avec quelques extraits extraits
as tu l'impression que c'était cette
élection est extrêmement décisive si
finalement la retrouve avoir été une
aberration de parenthèse bizarres des
leçons des états unis où qui est aussi
réélue un espèce de moments qui vont
complètement transformé le visage des
etats-unis profondément soit
excessivement pas c'est difficile de
revenir de ce puits après ce deuxième
volet commandant dépenses dans 20 ans on
va percevoir le président entrant
pauvreté qui est sic s'est passé c'était
quoi ce où ça veut savoir devenir une
normalité où ça va être un président
comme un autre nom
je pense que les quatre premières années
de trois ans nous ont montré ce à quoi
pourrait ressembler la politique
américaine c'est le reste au pouvoir
pour un long moment je pense que s'il
est réélu pour quatre ans sa vision de
la politique américaine ce qui leur
proposait sa manière de faire son côté
les attaques personnelles et tous
étaient là avant 3-1 électrum c'est sur
les stéroïdes
je pense que si les s'il est réélu pour
quatre ans ils vont inspirer justement
d'autres d'autres jeunes républicains à
faire la politique comme ça
pourquoi parce que ça marche un peu on
peut conclure que ça marche ça permet de
gagner des élections ça permet de tirer
son épingle du jeu et on voit déjà des
républicains qui tentent de faire la
politique comme il l'a fait dans une
publicité télévisée on a vu toutes
sortes de choses évidemment c'est moins
visé parce que ce sont ceux sont des
gens moins connus que trump qui le font
mais cette idée qu'on doit attaquer
cette idée qu'on ne doit pas faire de
compromis et tout ça c'est en train de
souffler est en train de prendre et
encore plus qu'avant parce que trump si
gang va démontrer que ça peut être
payant sur le plan électoral
donc ça fait une grande différence s'il
est réélu s'il ne fait qu'un mandat ben
oui on parlera peut-être un peu plus de
cette présidence comme étant une
parenthèse ce vers quoi on aurait pu
aller mais on a décidé de faire
autrement
c'est une bonne question puis pour ce
qui est du regard historique on fait du
regard qu'on va porter sur cette
présidence là dans 20 ans mais ça c'est
drôle parce que des fois les historiens
au début dit ça a été une très mauvaise
présidence mais réévalué après coup on
peut penser à george w bush bon
maintenant le comparer à trump c'est sûr
qui paraît peut-être mieux que grand
pour ceux qui a qui était critique de
ces deux présidents là parce qu'on voit
beaucoup plus loin avec trompe pas
encore mais je pense que dans 20 ans il
ya quand même des gens qui vont qui vont
dire que ce président là est tellement
reprises dans l'histoire
ouais ses partisans sont convaincus il
est le maire a pas qu'il est le meilleur
président que les états unis ont eu même
dans toute l'histoire de ce pays la même
trempe le dit lui-même de baisse
j'ai plus fait pour les afro-américains
qu'est brême linken un art il ya des
gens qui sont convaincus de cela et
qu'ils vont rester convaincu de ce peu
importe que ceux qui se parent je pense
pour les raisons qu'on a évoqué tantôt
les juges la cour suprême c'est un bon
exemple s'il est réélu pour quatre ans a
fait tout ça fait une grosse différence
différent si j'ai le feeling avec la
dernière année puis tout seul pour
reprendre encore une fois l'analyse et
qui disait d'étirer la démocratie mobile
fine que s'il est réélu pour quatre ans
ils vont y va essayer d'être élu encore
pour quatre autres années le fantôme et
oui le tir et que j'aurai tellement on
dirait que c'est tellement possible dans
ma tête quand j'ai quand je vois qu'en
ce moment il ce qui est en train de
faire par rapport aux élections puis à
discréditer toute seule je me dis ça me
surprendrait même pose que s'il réduit
en captant effacerait je peux rester
encore quatre autres années ouais il
joue un petit peu cette game là aussi
des fois sur twitter il voit là dessus
campagne électorale leur trame 2024
jeudi dire ça c'est juste comme placer
tranquillement des pions mais il ya un
cadre constitutionnel quand même qui dit
que le président ne peut ne peut pas
faire plus que deux mandats consécutifs
ati aussi les directions devrait être
final c'est qu'ils aient accès aux
civils
puis il faut pas oublier aussi qu'il ya
74 ans maintenant qu'il ya une limite à
ce qui peut faire lui personnellement
mais fait part lui qui ira long de sa
vie mais ce que je dirais sexy si réélu
pour quatre ans
là je pense qu'on peut peut-être
commencer à se dire qu'il pourrait y
avoir une dynastie trump aussi parce que
je le disais un peu tantôt c'était pour
ce n'est pas nécessairement la black je
le disais quand je parlais dans notre
homme junior
je pense que c'est je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui a des ambitions des
ambitions politiques
si son père perd l'élection 2020 ça
devient un petit peu plus difficile pour
les trams de continuer à surfer sur
l'idée qu'ils sont qui sont les gens de
la situation se marrent sommes ici
sitrom gagner l'élection 2020 pourquoi
pourquoi je pense que son fils pourrait
être tenté de poursuivre sur sa lancée
après ce deuxième mandat dont il serait
peut-être pas trompe lui-même qui serait
l'homme on sera un peu dans la même dans
la même dynamique et j'ai pas si vous
avez vu dans notre homme de juniors mais
c'est vraiment comme son père mais non
être encore exposants courir dans le
dans les attaques personnelles dans
c'est vraiment un discours pour la base
et pour la base de la base
est-ce que je dirais par rapport à 30,6
s'il est réélu il aura l'impression
d'avoir le monde de continuer ce qu'il a
en année pendant quatre ans et je pense
qu'il va y aller encore plus à fond très
nous dire que il n'aura pas le stress il
y aura plus d'élection un tri entre les
règlements il rend pas le stress d'être
réélu après mon peut-être qui pensera à
l'avenir politique de son fils rendu là
on verra mais je vois pas pourquoi c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a pas changé de ton ni
de discours en quatre ans et demi en
cinq ans si on inclut les mois où il a
pensé se lancer dans la campagne
présidentielle en 2015 la syrie et l'ue
pourquoi changeraient-ils changera pas
dit le virus n'y a pas changé il
changerait pas cirer lui je pense ça va
être ça va être peut-être encore plus
affirmé qu est ce qu on a vu durant les
quatre premières années
[Musique]
extrait après parce que j'espère que
jamais qu'ils soient chanteurs d'un ben
de métal les gens parce que ça serait
les bennes de plus stridents des
d'histoire parce que c'était ma voiture
dans un autre cas ce qu on pourrait
parler en fait c'est probablement les
podcasts et j'ai justement je te disais
si j'ai fait pour cette question à nos
abonnés ceux restés cois leurs coups de
coeur puis mettez les gens ont
sensiblement les mêmes coups de coeur
que nous beaucoup de gens qui ont sorti
mais un nom qui remontent tous sortis
c'est le podcast avec maïté saganash qui
était vraiment un autre pack ans
vraiment à propos au niveau du timing
niveau de l'ère du star 2020 des
revendications sociales c'était une
année de bagasse plus sociale ça c'était
vraiment un bon thé est vraiment
impressionnante mais était le titre je
réclame aussi des extraits le tipi et
akon à maîtrise encore une fois son
sujet du bout de ses doigts tu qu'elle a
trempé dans cette dans cet univers le de
la politique sont pas en reparler
l'extrait ça c'est drôle que son père il
dit il faut qu au président j quand
est-ce que trudeau vos avoué qu'ils
donnent des phoques de nice people qui
était gréviste est extrait le tell tale
l'écouté tantôt au maine ces bons ne
s'excuserait pas demandé de s'excuser
pire il fait excuser moi mais je pas
capable mais même en charge des sports
c'est bon mais mais moi c'est otis
ce qui m'a marqué je prends de
conversation le peut-être c'est
l'extrait qu'on peut choisir c'est bah
c'est la question des dépenses ionitx
parti québécois qui est une page très
sombre de cette histoire puis qu'il
conduisait avec elle on t on est
quasiment toute idée
jamais entendu parler avant l'université
sait à quel point c'est quelque chose
qu'on qu'on essaye de culte et le
trident de 13 en mémoire collective
ça n'a aucun sens tpiy les coupes c'est
la chose qui me connaissent le petit
cours d'histoire à l'université ces gens
avec ça c'est des maisons langues
[Rires]
je vais apprendre à propos des maisons
longue quand je vais m'intéresser
vraiment la culture mais part maudite
somme l'histoire la vie des autochtones
au québec ces postures mais c'est pas
les maisons longue oui ça fait partie de
la culture mais l'histoire s'est on est
arrivé ici puis on les autres tu es le
pigeon c'est ce que ces procès avant les
maisons l'ong ti ou les maisons longues
étaient là avant que ça se passe même
sommes en ordre de priorité pourquoi il
ya plus de maisons longue ici en ce
moment pour parler pourquoi les espaces
et si on a parlé je te mentir parler de
racisme plutôt pis on a parlé de 6 soit
le de ce côté plus sombre de sombrer ça
permettait de comprendre les
problématiques maintenant vivre au lieu
de juste dire mais celui-ci c'est
d'essayer typhon six pieds puis comme
sous-entendre que c'est de leur faute et
maintenant je sais bien qu il tablait le
malheur qui vivaient là qu'on arrive à
quai mais tipi puis-je a menti encore
une fois n'a été si l'histoire très
récente
dernier oui passionnant ce n'est pas ce
que disent ces 96 96 j'ai peu le ton est
alors monté le traitement par a passé
dix ans passionné n'est pas capable d'en
parler sans pleurer tipi fax est pas l
affaire lointaine cécile 3 contient 1810
mettons maïté même si elle même est pas
allé aux passionnés les pensionnats
l'affect directement directement parce
que le c'est son père ses saisons que
ses grands parents qui ont vécu ce
traumatisme la pinta mathis jeudi après
si tu as la percée le traumatisme
intergénérationnel c'est comme tututu
tout le temps semaines je dirais que
kiki citoyens et manque d'un traumatisme
après cet aspect que keita et des
lacunes
qu'ils étaient dictés enfants ok tease
fake c'est une douleur et une souffrance
qui se transmet puis je trouvais qu'elle
exprimait vraiment bien puis que ça
permet 0 entendre qu on vraiment de
comprendre mais premièrement mieux cette
réalité là c'est peut-être cette
communauté depuis cette souffrance le
site ont constitué clairement un moment
fort de ce podcast lancé quand je lui ai
demandé qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce qui
est qu'est ce qui s'en vient pour toi tu
veux faire
sa réponse a juste été bon j'aimerais
vraiment ça me rend dans les points
puisque j'ai plus besoin de parler de ma
culture mais je pourrais juste la vie ça
jamais rester kressmann comme half men
les revendications des peuples
autochtones c'est juste deux ans ce
moment maintenant c'est comment qu'on
fait pour réparer tout seul c'est juste
crise et nous la paix juste vivent bien
de chez nous la peine
c'est tout ce que je veux accepter les
torts vous nous avez fait piquer c'est
nous la paix laisser nos moteurs qui
recevra peu extrême un extrait extrême a
été extrait mais tant pis je pense que
les gens réalisent pas non plus que ça
s'est passé pas dans mes vidéos
il ya encore des vidéos puis de somme
toute bonne qualité mais les derniers
passionnés qui fermait 85
je m'en souviens 96 e majine souvenir de
80 c'est justement parlons je te
demander des pensionnats parce que moi
ça me terrifie
l'idée que j'ai jamais entendu parler
des pensionnats jusqu'à l'université
j'ai fait mon cégep lé jusqu'à temps que
j'arrive à l'université ou est ce que
j'avais un cours de littérature engagée
c'est une des étudiantes qui apparaît de
tu le manges entendu comme telle
histoire de viol l'histoire de deux
d'enlèvement enlèvement l'histoire de
disparition complète
l'idée d'assimiler complètement une
culture du lin théo c'est exactement ça
puis moi j'ai appris cela l'a fait dans
le calme à l'appel à parler de tout
comme si comme si c'était une
connaissance ti mais je veux dire j'ai
fait quand même et des études j'ai passé
à travers tout mon processus primaire
niveau secondaire collégial sans jamais
entendre parler de ce fait que les
pensionnats en fait c'était peu tu ne
peux tu nous en parler pour les gens qui
écoutent qui comme moi peut-être sont
juste pas au courant que ça s'est passé
ici ça existe ça a été pendant des
centaines d'années puis ça a été
vraiment pour s'il était vraiment
politique d'assimilation en fait pour
pour assimiler les autochtones en feutre
pour les rendre civilisé puis type les
gens pensent que c'est vraiment en lui
même on parlera passé dix ans dans les
pensées nomme même étant maison que j'ai
même un nombre qui mord aux pensées
naquit oms a pris 40 à macau qu'on sache
y étaient enterrés ou non ouais et avait
peur qu'ils ont été chanceux parce que
l'abe
la dame qui le vus sur son lit de mort
as avec à côté qu' il est enterré
parce qu'à dix ans je m'en suis l'on
enterré à côté d'une dame du village
qu'on connaît cet essai mais il s'était
pas marqué rien puis on lui a fallu
remonter ma tante c'était journal et sa
sibiti pendant leur auteur pendant 40
ans puis c'est elle qui a ramené les
images à ma grand moine qui ma grand
mère tu sais si oui c'est ce qu'un
projet ça fait 2 mai qui ont également
la famille demander ce que tu veux qu'on
rapatrie les le corps pialat les prix ne
pose pas le dire non je sais qu'on veut
je sais qu'on va se rencontrer encore un
jour puis ma grand marais
décédé il y en a toujours mais avec ce
mess fcc tous les gens pensent que c'est
dans les années 1800 pieds les télés il
faut des gens n'auraient glas mais c'est
surtout très simple mais non vraiment ça
comme ça je sais a relaté cette histoire
que ça te rend fébrile c'est juste
quatre ans parce que entre que je veux
dire premièrement on commence à pas de
casse mais si je pense que on doit quand
même merci de venir ici de dents volé la
force pile courage puis la patience et
d'en parler parce que tu dois être tenté
tout le temps de parler de cette
histoire le pen c'est sûr mais c'est
quand mon pari tout pas mon père était
huit ans au parlement puis à chaque fois
le parti lui demandait de faire des
commentaires là dessus ou quand il y
avait des questions là-dessus enchante
de les adresser puis je pense que c'est
pas aux survivants de faire ceux ci ont
déjà assez union de ses souffre de vivre
cette expérience je pense qu'on peut les
laisser tranquilles même fait que moi
j'essaie de faire ce que j'essaie de
faire ça pour ma famille j'ai cette
force aux poumons pas parce que moi je
veux mon père à chaque jour de
commémoration ce jeune chef d puis c'est
la journée nationale pour c'est quand
même le riz des survivants puis mon
parti il tant il est en larmes à chaque
jeudi comment faut il faut que tu
puisses my dad back together
mais je sait pas toujours comment faire
parce que c'est ce que ça fait les
pensionnés aussi que ça le salon créer
une cassure dans les communications dans
les dents libre - de communication en
fait cesser ces gens là ne grandit dans
la souffrance ont grandi dans la
violence
puis opus et ses enseignements de base
comment communiquer non plus - s'ils
sont avec mon père c'est d'aider des
fois je voudrais qu'ils me disent
comment faire mais il y est pas hyper
capable
[Musique]
wright
on est de retour web barre l world back
bébé le podcast de commencer un très
long feu quand ils ont enfin comme de
petites dimensions en narratrice taire
ceux qui sont venus mais il y en a plein
d'autres sûrement plein d'autres bons
pas de casse un instant et pas de
podcasts
cette année on ne veut pas de casque
m'ont déçu non c'est trop de casse
sinon nos préférences mais des fois même
les préférences du monde sont pas les
mêmes et il n'y a pas une discussion que
je regrette d'avoir eu ou que je me dis
arrive tu es vraiment pas pertinent
chaque personne avait quelque chose
d'absolument unique à nous partager puis
c'est tout le temps tout le temps
intéressante structures ont garanti tout
le temps à chaque fois fait que si on
promet des extraits puis ont préparé de
tous les podcasts allemande mais on n'a
pas le temps de le faire
exact mais mettons vite de même le pti
je pense qu on est premier on a parlé
brièvement dans tout autre que sa fille
camille roy et me leroy pour parler
d'environnement
c'était comme vraiment un condensé de
com de fax sur l'environnement c'est
vraiment commence par l'égoïsme
connaissez la foire il fait beaucoup de
recherches avancées vidéo et puis c'est
là qu'elle frappe c'est un influenceur
des kilos qualité des leads via
influence la qualité certaine au dessus
toi moi moi ya gabriella deux bois quand
leur su pour la deuxième fois pardon gab
gamme
maintenant c'est au début après fois
qu'on leur suzel deuxième podcast sans
filtre on y en avait pas une relation
cordiale d'accès avec on le connaissait
en fait à proprement dire enfin qui est
arrivé un petit peu plus en mode
politiciens l'oeil
là on le connaissait et on se parlera
kamkar qui vient city fait qu on a une
relation avec lui est beaucoup plus les
bacs beaucoup plus amical puis je
comprends absolument les tic ainsi que
ce n'est pas des gens tu arrives point
les bacs
effectivement une des affaires en fait
puis en ce moment c'est ce que je trouve
qui étoffe avec la situation politique
au québec c'est que moi je trouve que ça
manque de charisme
puis ça manque de quelqu'un qui donne
envie de le suivre et puis petit jeu le
goïc en gestionnaires ti
c'est beaucoup plus un gestionnaire
qu'un leader dit l'autre jour et je
m'appuie en étant ça on est élu on a vu
il m'a parlé même si on s'y met à rire
les tiges et ce à cause des quilles et
le type alors un pilote et clip baby gab
il dégage puis on l'a vu dans le
printemps arabe est une chose on était
des rues qu'on le suivait le dentiste
rubens goya à 21 21 ans qui était un bon
leader pour qui tu es capable justement
de dégâts le galvaniser une population
en ti des deux départements le suivre
pour une cause pour des idées aux pieds
c'est en boîte il ya une raison que je
vote pour qu'avec celle d'ap c'est pas
nécessairement parce que en accord avec
toutes leurs politiques mais c'est
clairement parce que parce que je veux
quelqu'un qui comme ce qui me donne
envie de le sucre même choqué gablé pas
d'accord avec toutes les politiques de
québec solidaire mais que c'est un parti
fec fo en étant dos le biais du parti
une parade et si tu t'attends de trouver
un parti avec lequel tu vas être 100%
d'accord sur tout chacun voit son propre
parti de ces spots exactement vrai que
tu trouves le parti qu avec les quelques
plus le meilleur dénominateur commun dit
dans bams tracé exact chaque mois de
plus que pour le goût mais c'est un bon
pas de casse puisque à ce moment là on
ne fait un espèce de tour d'horizon de
l'actualité puis deux
si on est un ami les croissance forte au
québec l'indépendance économique du
québec
c'était vraiment commencé on était en
pleine pandémie en plein soulèvement
social sont plusieurs causes ce terme
intéressant par sa mort de façon les
d'backs qui quinze jours puis avec un
gars qui réfléchit à toutes ces
questions la main sur n'importe quelle
question d'actualité ou non après
quelques débats puis il ya des jeux
serait pas très bon à sa job s'il était
prêt à te répondre à n'importe quelle
question qui le gérait fléchi facchetti
c'était vraiment mais y est fascinant
voir aller à quel point c'était ce genre
dgo tu prends une question pelé va dire
trois points épineux sujet posé contre
lui ça devait pas être trop chiant et
faire une dissertation à l'école vous
avez huit pas de ses passions genre je
peux tu l'as fait avant la pause le
monde qui sait les ce thème organisée
dans l'artère ma clope c'est un mac on
sait que je dois leur speech et une
concertation teulet libre et sans
vraiment haute mention honorable
mention honorable
je voudrais j'allais aller ce parc est
je pense une mention honorable je pense
que certains dans encore une fois la
catégorie podcast disons mettons social
twitter s'est démarqué n'a été cette
marque c'est de marquer puis d'anti le
ton est un autre sujet mais alice si la
marque et puis les gens aussi leurs
longs l'on dit sur les réseaux sociaux
pmc j'ai trouvé vraiment rigoureuses
préparer c'était honteux on était potes
que dans le dans l'expérience dans leur
essence il était aussi dans les faits
puis dans pi date dans la nuance ou si
on a parlé d'eux quand ils culture puis
des réhabilitations t je pense que je
pense que c'est important d'en parler
parce que c'est important que ça soit
possible mais ton pour quelqu'un qui ait
commis des actes répréhensibles temps
quelqu'un qui était quand les autres qui
qui avait une réhabilitation possible
qui est sa première fois qui comme
parler du concept de justice réparatrice
de tiges trait au sport intéressant puis
d'ailleurs on commence à voir justement
les je trouve comment savoir l'espèce de
travail de justice réparatrice qui fait
aimer ton alex nevsky et en disant que
justement cette semaine qu'elle est née
skik télé les deux camps disent on s'est
parlé on s'est réconciliés on est
correct puis on doute on arrête d'en
parler de saint george russell phone de
voir qui il ya eu il ya eu acte mettant
il ya eu problématique qui a eu
dénonciation il ya eu 8 ravaille pu
réconciliation depuis ce jour c'est
vraiment beau de voir qu'on est capable
de se rendre à ce point-là de
réconciliation on tourne la page on
passe à autre chose se fait que ça je
trouve ça cool je trouve ça cool que
quiconque on a pu aborder ces sujets lot
6 matches dans le même ordre d'idée
ouais t'as pour finir le amant qui
attendait après
m mention spéciale à une des
personnalités web qui a eu le plus de
présence dans les derniers mois
si juliette juliette bélanger carpentier
au karpaty belgique belgique apprentis
bg je pense bg je viens de bg de larges
caps entier tombe et signe en fait et b
saint martin et qui est aussi était
impeccable sur le podcast est arrivée
ici avec toute sa connaissance pis elle
faisait elle aussi dans la nuance
on a eu cette discussion la guettait qui
était ultra points puis il très
pertinentes au moment où est-ce qu'on
lui puis en fait jeudi une des personnes
web les plus recommandés de 2020 est ce
parce que chaque fois qu'a fait un
public à sion tout le temps extrêmement
une pointe extorquant partagé par des
des centaines de personnes personnes
super cool à suivre qu'on ait eu
extrêmement du plaisir à recevoir je
peux tu y as toi rapido le juste parce
que ça passe j'ai rentré ce pack à ce
rallye je trouvais que chaque palette de
cathy devient connu d'essayer de faire
l'effort conscient de prendre position
près de rester grande et de pas utiliser
ton pouvoir védasien puis de 10 du titre
celle encore avec est avec ses amis du
secondaire ou de thé du temps qui sont 0
quand on utilise trouve ça le fun de ce
colloque est moi qui ai vraiment
vraiment orateurs qui est qui qui fait
le choix conscient je demande de le
rester - rapido jeff ya vraiment pas de
casque les croisés à verdun autres nous
regardent et je suis sûr qu'ils me
reconnaissent
c'est encore une fois j'en ai invités
experts expriment bien qui est bon piqué
qui nous aura permis de comprendre qu'on
prenait pour moi c'était quoi le
mouvement qui met en avant qui nous
l'expliquent puis c'est porte pas de
casque qui donne le plus c'est un sport
mais tente parce que c'est très drôle
parce que j'ai réécouté justement des
buts à atteindre ses pieds
on a parlé maintenant la conversion des
loges
mais non ça qu'une guerre civile que ça
vient avec des fillettes mn lancé yves
il a pu finalement quand le hall échappe
t jeudi leur patron on a réussi à
l'éviter
moi j'ai pas l'impression finalement que
les conserves obama c'était attendu
je prends une moche passé c'est le sait
les médias qui ont réussi à faire mourir
dans l'oeuf
parce qu'il reste fille mais tant que
fonction ce qu'amd pour de vrai elle a
fallu qu'ils ont dit m un des médias aux
etats unis 50 pour de vrai dans une
position pas suite à l'élection le
décrit comme stan fraude ou à 9 heures
puis que là il fait cette information là
j'aurais pu déraper mais là comme on
disait tantôt le mot l'ont tellement
fermé liv rapidement la journée ou sas
annoncé que ben laden avait gagné
c'était de terminer un pire personne qui
lui en fait les médias on était vraiment
plus responsable que le président des
états unis m ce dernier met en jeu très
rose aimée qui est juste trop forte le
tellement brillante s'exprime tellement
bien pis téléphone pour parler avec
quelqu'un d'aussi briand qui une
féminisme et de sexualité de manière
vraiment ouverte il ya la conversation
autour des petits copains de 6 pi c'est
sa conversation téléphonique avec m6
kids et wat et féministe de type 3
semaines c'est si je sais trop comique
les facs et ouais ça c'était vraiment
mon podcast ou si je pensais qu'on sait
clairement c'est un rapport pour notre
année ouais on remercie tous les autres
stades sans fil
si vous étiez pas le on ne serait pas là
tout à fait c'est clair ça c'est clair
on remercie tout le monde au studio
quelqu'un si toute notre équipe aussi du
sénegal il ya une année record
on est rendus 150 tous
clairement nicole qui est maire single
pour la belle année du sans-fil podcast
est tout le temps impeccable tout le
temps de pointe puis tout le temps aussi
vraiment facile à bouquet dernière
minute c'est quand même un peu j'en
avais déjà parlé m'a toute façon assange
vit quasiment ici c'est pour ça qu'on ne
m'ait pas d'acheter le futon ya un maire
single à mazet pour être un pro fait une
job impeccable pour - bah j'essaye
j'essaie vraiment de faire de mon mieux
puis c'était pas le prêt pour faire ce
qu'on fait mais non c'est sûr que non
c'est sûr que non on traîne trop bas
merci
c'est vraiment gentil même moi je vous
retourne apparaît aussi je trouve
vraiment excellent comme pas de gaspi
souvent en fait c'est le monde demande
en fait souvent si c'est quoi genre
c'est quoi qui fait un bon pas de casse
et toupie jeu comme et écouter écouter
le sans fil de n'importe quel épisode
dans ma pauvre il s'agissait je suis
vraiment vraiment en être les jeudis
écouter n'importe quel épisode sans
faute avec un invité qui qui qui vous et
qui vous allume un peu lui qui avait
avec votre podcast où vous êtes assurés
d'avoir un niveau de qualité et le thé
comme minimum le terrain genre de celle
de qualité comme qui est qui et qui
commet certifier son fils vous êtes
vraiment vraiment des estivants
podcasteurs merci et je l'envoie là j'en
écoute vraiment vraiment beaucoup
puis je le pense encore le tuer fait que
mercy main pauvres
merci beaucoup encore une fois merci à
toi qui les écoute puis on vous souhaite
une bonne année on soit en 2021
rafraîchissant et besoin un qui gérait
bien votre stress
puis encore